no I have a guy who can go into your
computer and do it
Winnie and he'll just go through all
your like photos who's this guy videos
he's like he's um this Ukrainian guy
he's really cool that's he sounds great
yeah when he does it for free which is
like so that's weird nice of him guys
are so nice I mean guys are just like no
ulterior motives never oh they're so
nice are we recording look cute she
looks are we recording on my computer
not yet not yet have to go I'm glad
thank you for looking so what I think oh
I just thought we had the same ring no
we don't we I have a similar ring oh
it's horse of course it's a horse shoes
all horse stuff yeah I know you have a
horse but I don't think of you as a
horse person well most horse person
people are fucking annoying as shit I'm
a horse person who isn't like an anal
retentive like you don't wear a
turquoise belt buckle
I buy them but I don't wear
them I just I paused I get yeah I know
because we're recording oh okay I mean
sorry to no I buy them just so no one
else can have them I see the things you
buy and I'm I'm
impressed I'm impressed but I want to
know how you clean them like do you
immediately like do you wipe off the
plastic and then take the thing out and
then wash it like what do you do you
mean in this new CL in The New Normal
yeah The New Normal I I'm going to
actually tell you what I do are we
recording you're all good so now when I
buy something mhm I'll bring it in turn
on the
oven are you shitting me nope you're
gonna burn your house down you can't
cook but will there be any Co in my home
Maybe not maybe not man and a sauna you
can turn the sauna up and put things in
the sauna and it kills it that's fine so
the oven is not okay I only know how to
cook
packages well when I moved in I turned
my oven on to be like I wonder how hot
this gets and then I opened it and the
the manual for the oven was in the
oven and I had cooked
it was like huh weird this oven smells
weird just a a completely Brown smoking
book maybe that's what Sylvia Plath was
doing oh yeah that's that's what we were
all inhaling back then the poets so I
just burning spines I just want to start
this with number one what's the Band-Aid
on your finger oh God thank you for
noticing I knew you would well you keep
drinking it up to the I'm
just of
coffee uh it's boring I just scratched
myself and here's what's annoying I cut
all my nails off cuz my natural nails
had gotten really long the way my old
fake nails used to get and I was like
this is so great this is so great and
then I was like this is so dumb what am
I
doing I thought you I thought you were
going to say I cut my finger putting it
in my cat's mouth oh well there's
there's also ass sorted little cat cat
bites no I just scraped the shit out of
myself with my short harmless Nails I'm
not doing much my fingers look like
sweet potato fries in they look great
but we don't need to do this like this
one of those things that like why and I
loved having cute nails and I did my own
gels and I like watched a million
YouTube videos like my thing that I did
and now I don't give a shit about
anything anymore are you just in a full
existential crisis uhhuh Yep this is I I
did my face and my hair for you I was
gonna say this is I want to deconstruct
everything that's happening here because
I feel like there was a blowout was
there a blowout wish I could do that
myself also you wish I had layers you to
blow out like you these are my bangs
from two years ago that are that are not
all the way back that's it the moment
your bangs turn into tendrils that's
quarantine Chic and if you fucking think
I hav't all I do is I look at your
little thing your little videos and I go
that's the length that's the length I
need that's what I want have you ever
had short short hair no whoa if I just
basically it looks so good got out of a
relationship and was just like fuck it
fuck you and fuck this and this these my
hair was like hey it was it was like the
second I would get out of the shower it
was already dry and that's when you know
you got to do something about it this
from here down it's dry after like 10
minutes and this stays wet for years you
look
unbelievable okay okay okay 480 old man
thank you you know I will say my Skin's
doing all right Flawless it's doing all
right well it's not Flawless it's doing
all right um because I'm not putting on
any makeup except for today I want to
say a couple things before we start
start number one it I can't even begin
to tell you how much I wasn't going to
ever asked you to do this
podcast but but I would have been sad
because
I like I don't want to ever do anything
but I listen to your podast I listen so
weird actually I'm gonna take this
opportunity to tell you I so I have a
terrible phobia of flying I think I've
said this to you before I think I know
that okay I I have a ve I mean I I do it
because I have to for work or I did not
not anymore
goodbye bye jobs a goodbye um and the
only way that I can stay uh in my body
without leaving it
permanently listen to podcasts and now
that you have a podcast it's like this
person I know is doing this thing and it
grounds me and it makes me less scared
and your episode with um Dave Gro a I
listened to that episode on the way home
from Georgia and I first of all was
weeping when he was talking about all
that shit weeping and it was such a I
was just I don't know it really it's
great
you I love you I love listening to my
friends podcast because it's all the
things I love about my friends without
having to chime in or have an opinion I
don't have to say anything like you're
you're doing it I can just hear you talk
and like listen to your wisdom and like
hear you say things about therapy and
I'm like
M it's like but I can just stay a lazy
person's dream
conversation yeah like I don't have to
tap dance for you people I have to make
you laugh like you feel like um kind of
just like a a zar when you listen to
podcast like you guys make me laugh
entertain I'm just GNA sit here naked in
my tub Turkey
Leg exactly but with you because I know
you well it feels not as weird to enjoy
it so much you know CU otherwise it's
like my friends that I don't know oh
that's kind of true talk to me you know
so it feels less weird and creepy but it
I think you and I my nightmare is being
asked to do someone else's
podcast and less it's unless like the
only reason I asked is because you
probably haven't seen a human being in
two months that's true right and yes I
see the kind of things you're doing to
pass the time I can dare tell you're
bored this you mean what is that just
that what is that a about you it's a
Nintendo switch oh it's a okay it's
where I live and what are we playing
we're playing Animal Crossing and Animal
Crossing only I don't need to play that
because I have an animal crossing in my
home I know you
do but I will say it's the only thing
keeping me from completely losing my
shit like I'm finding myself sort of
like wanting to do things that I
wouldn't normally do like podcasts are
because here's the thing about you I was
like I'll never ask her to do the
podcast because the hardest part of
about doing a podcast with your friends
isn't hanging out with them and talking
to them it's the drive it's the getting
there it's the not being this is perfect
I'm not you know I'm I'm a a terrible
driver I'm I hate driving yeah that
tracks you know this you you met me
before I could drive because I drove
right yes maybe just as I got my I know
that you don't like being hit by cars in
TV
shows oh I sure oh that's right no who
who would I know that every now and then
when a car is coming at you 60 MPH it's
not your favorite thing you know I can't
say that it is I it's just one of those
weird quirks I have there's like a point
in making uh a television show where
you're just like asking the actors just
jump off buildings just have cars hit
them I'm at but I've reached the point
where I'm like I'm no longer doing this
shit anymore because you're not going to
use it so true you're you're not you're
cutting you're cutting way you're
cutting to the wide you're cutting to
the wide yep I don't need to be within
five feet of this you're just fucking
have someone some nice
lovely athletic human person it could
even be sometimes it's a dude that's
right way it doesn't matter no one cares
fix yeah there's Snapchat filters where
you can make me look like a full
dinosaur I know I know you can do this
in post I know you can 100% I'm done and
I'm actually proud of myself cuz I was
just before this I was doing something
and there was and I had hurt my ankle a
couple years ago real bad and I was in a
I was in a boot for 12 weeks oh and um
there was a scene where I'm running
through a
field and I I get to to the night shoot
and there's no stunt on the call sheet
and I'm like I wonder if they don't have
a stunt cuz we talked about this months
ago and it's probably forgotten and so I
brought it up they were like oh
um I was
like now now I'm difficult because I
well I was like here's the thing I'll do
it I can't guarantee my ankle will make
it to tomorrow oh but they were like no
problem they got someone to come in we
shot other stuff first and then they got
a stunt woman to come in and she didn't
and it was great yeah that's the first
time I've ever never said that only
because I was like you guys don't know
what's going to happen if you have
actually taught me so much about like
claiming your space because uh a friend
of mine uh was no but just because like
if I hurt myself we're all fucked we're
all fucked yeah you know like I'm not a
nice person for hurting myself if I
catch on fire no one has a job right and
I know that I need to be like a good
sport and I don't want to be seen as
difficult but like I suck it up and do
this thing that my gut is telling me
this is dangerous and everyone's going
to rush and everyone wants to go home
and everyone want like knock my gut is
telling me this is a bad idea now I'm
the one that has to in front of 200
people say like I don't I know and now
you know but like it sucks however it it
created it was a two-minute conversation
it held nobody up nobody we just did one
other shot first while the stunt woman
put the wig on and they got everything
they needed and I still have a ligament
I still have one of my limbs no
guarantees everybody
wins oh this ankle was I know so many
actors who have been injured I remember
a friend of mine was working on a show
in Vancouver she was pregnant and had to
go into a water tank and okay and the
the top had smoke coming out of it like
it was like and she was just like no
maybe not actually like of course not
it's already in my deal that if I'm like
I had to let you know she 5 years in
advance she had to say I'm going to be
pregnant one day and there's going to be
no smoke I can't inhale the smoke
because it's one like Smoky shows oh got
it and then she's shows up to work
there's a giant water tank and a bunch
of smoke machines and she's like so now
I'm the asshole who has
to just be the yeah you can't inh you
know what that you know what's in that
smoke it's like it's like coffee grounds
from the from the 1800s it's like
garbage it's bad like every time I have
to inhale that stuff I get like weird I
get like siny weird it's not good
meanwhile all the crew is in masks and
she's like pregnant like what like what
is this like absolutely not no you gotta
say you got to say you don't have to say
you don't have to be crazy all the time
because sometimes you just got to do
some stuff but just don't be in danger
and also if I'm in fear this isn't going
to be
funny yeah I can't commit to this like
okay people live for no it's not going
to be funny if a woman's in fear it's
gonna be sexy we like it that's
right get it straight it sweep sweet can
you cry stand up seems I can't think of
anything more terrifying than stand up
that's so interesting I know yeah but
that's where we're just different like
you however like well first I think of
you as having a stand up brain and yep
wait for it you won't even remember this
but when the first time we worked
together like in the first couple days
there was this scene and the costomer
had given you a purse that was almost it
was like a vintage like I remember this
goddamn purse yeah it was like flat it
was like a flat purse it was like a it
was like a flounder that's exactly right
and I said I said I was like what would
ever fit in here and you were like a
flounder oh shit I just said my own joke
no but you it was like that's it and it
was like only someone that can write
jokes would think like that like that
fast you were just like a
flounder and I was like oh yeah like
that's like on some like Genius Like
Next Level shit well I didn't remember
it and I still said you're still a
genius after all these years it's funny
you bring up those days because I have a
little surprise for you
Whitney you may not remember probably
the same the same week as the story you
just told me there was a LOL shooting
something and you came over because I
was probably yeah you came over to me to
sit in the set with me because I was
probably overtly panicking and crying
about something oh oh pumpkin my cat had
just passed away that's and you were
being so sweet and you were talking to
me and we were talking about it because
we're both you know animal people and
you you had a ring on and you were like
and and I was like oh that's so pretty
and you just took it off your finger and
gave it to
me and look who still has
it thank God you took that cuz you are
the only person that can pull that off
no you were wearing a you were doing a
great job was I doing Wiccan rituals
like who I don't know that is pretty
great 10 years since that conversation
and I I still have it I do think I had
that
made do you want it back no I you know
what yeah I do
can you come drop it off in in these
times of Co a week drive by and 50 miles
an hour that really touches my
heart well good because I it touches
mine because I I wear it like I love
this ring this makes me so happy because
I feel like you have this incredible
like timeless style like we used to
always say about you like she's just
like from the 30s
or something you have like I if I was
going to buy jewelry for you I to
wouldn't totally know where to go it'd
be hard for me you and me both I that's
very nice I would go Victorian I think
oh you got you got it aren't you like a
Victorian look look at you see that flag
and what is this Taxidermy what are we
looking at this is is the apaka what can
you see what can you oh that no this
looks like Sherlock's
laboratory thank you that's what I
was it's a clo is this a is this a
Oddities
Emporium kind of that's kind of the vibe
I like actually this chair is from Ikea
for those of you listening to the
podcast I'm looking at lots of like
beakers and glass it's not a beaker I'm
not doing experiments I think I see a
chemistry set a vintage stochiometry
periodic
table what is that is that a pine cone
in a glass a pine cone in a clo and then
there's a Candlestick and another bigger
clo and where do you find these uh CH
big clo I got on Etsy it's from the
1800s fantastic a little clo is from
Ikea from the now
times you can do a mix of high low you
could be a crazy person and still save a
couple bucks I love all this I do have
and here I got to I got to say I've the
crystal thing Los Angeles has ruined it
I know it's such a bummer crystals
cool and now they're corny I used to go
to gem shows I used to I was a member of
the Pasadena lapidary Society excuse me
a thing that I did is lap lapis is that
lapidary I don't know it has something
to do with minerals but it was like I I
love minerals and the and the whole
thing and like I collected things and I
went to these shows and now I just seem
like another douchy La actress with like
a bunch of crystals out like I feel like
Jared letto has an iteration of that
that bastard is always copying me yeah
like John vados did that like in his
store you know what I mean like way
after you already doing mad about it and
then's some good shit over there so how
are you what are you how are you passing
your time during the new
normal um I well uh pretty bad badly
doing bad
um uh doing very bad never look better
so thank you well you know skin care is
not happening either but for some reason
it's working out I don't know um I'm
obsessively washing my hair every day uh
just because I feel like I'm I was
already slightly agoraphobic but this
now it's just all it's ruined it's
ruined because now I'm like oh there's
there's shit everywhere that can kill
anyone any one of us I'm just going
really far with this the invisible
murderers are just running a I like my
murderer obvious visible well it's also
tricky because it's like all of the
social cues just flipped right so two
months ago if you saw someone in a mask
that was a scary criminal you run away
from that that's a murder now if you're
wearing a mask you're like H responsible
love that guy right right and if
someone's not wearing a mask you're like
murderer oh 100% just flipped 100% And I
I actually got a tablecloth out cu I'm
going to start making homemade masks I
love so that'll be a fun look forward to
that content on my social I'm also so
such a paranoid person that my brain
goes okay everyone's in masks now
crime's going to go up because everyone
can be in masks all the time right and
if you listen to a lot of True Crime
podcast and read a lot of True Crime
things like I do you're just like this
is bad and this is bad as it gets
something else I will say I think
something that's going to stick that I'm
fine with is we will not handshake again
that those days are over goodbye bye I
don't need it you don't need it we never
needed it never needed it what is this
why never needed it also I don't need to
do this also as a woman when you shake
hands with someone especially a man you
instantly get a grade on how your
handshake was oh it's like oh it's a
strong show little lady with has a
strong handshake and then you have to be
like yeah like and then I have if you do
the like the like Floppy Fish handshake
they're like they're like I expected
this from you yeah totally like it's
just then I have to get graded on my
handshake based on my size I've gotten
complimented on my handshake by so many
people and I'm
like and then and then I'm like what why
do I have to feel good about that I have
a handshake like that I did like they're
like I just got a good strong handshake
like like yeah I know I I have a an arm
yeah connected to like I have a Hello
also just don't say anything just shut
up about it good morning thank you also
I'm gonna be just like I'm just G if I
if someone comes at me like they forgot
I'm just gonna go
slap slap it down I'm mace fully mace
them I think hugs are over don't need
them I'm never needed them I I that's
it's gross I never needed them never
wanted them CU women onom hugs you're
just trying to like not fuck up each
other's hair anyway ex yeah and then
with men and then if you're hugging a
tall man it's like you know that like a
little bit of your highlighter is going
to get on his dumb shirt and we together
now yeah if my head hits your shoulder
yeah it's just like a little bit of my
highlighter pressing our like Earthly
shells on one another it's a wild ritual
we don't need it and it's just all this
stuff can go 90% of everything can go
100% 100% that
90% 90% of the time 100% making and then
when you see men and they come like for
a hug I'm like I don't need this like I
think you didn't hug any of the guys why
do I get a hug yeah because you know why
I know why I cuz I want to hug Whitney
and she's big that's why this is my only
shot but also you don't really it's like
and then I'm always like my boobs are
fake are you are we taking I I always
feel like I they're they went numb
they're numb I can't feel anything but I
so I don't know how hard I'm hugging cuz
I can't really feel and then I feel try
to next time someone hugs you try to
knock the wind out of them
try to disarm them completely and just
like deflate both their lungs at once
and then they drop like a stone and
that's the last time they try that
that's such a
funny
like just like headbutt
them like so wildly violent just try to
hurt them as hard as you can't I mean
it's just it's I think there are certain
things that will just never be the same
like when I see someone talking on their
phone with it to their face I'm
like I know in what world is your phone
I'm spraying shit all over this phone I
don't even go anywhere first of all can
you show the people watching what this
phone is what is this phone what is this
what am I looking at uh this is from the
before time but that's the back of the
phone not it on Amazon let me see that
wait it's like the Sailor Moon it makes
your your phone look like an old pH oh
my God that's so cute I
know
it's also for a phone with I actually
have three lenses it's the newer phone
but I just decided to forget about that
lens for the sake of how cute this is it
is so adorable it does give me a little
bit of Joy looking at it a lot of people
have questions about you because you're
you have incredibly good taste what
incredibly good taste who says this
you're making it up the internet Reddit
Benton Benton Benton has a question
Benton does have a lot of question
Benton doesn't understand why you're so
good at putting on eyeliner thank you he
says does she use a liquid eyeliner it
is a liquid eyeliner okay and how do you
do that without um looking like you're
going through a divorce practice okay oh
well you gotta keep your eyes open takes
takes practice pull your eye
never here's why gonna get real
technical please and as I'm aging um I
can't do what I used to be able to do
which is like a nice sharp point up
because my my eyelid is you know
descending into my
face um so you gotta like change shit up
but you just keep your got to ride the
horse in the direction it's going that's
right time Flows In One Direction okay
so you just do with one hand one hand
you go start in the inner I stop right
in the
middle then I do I just do a thin line
at the end decide where I want my point
start up at the point go down
meet the rest this way keep your eye
open and go real slow I have to use a
real
pointy um you're you're like you're in
tomorrow you're like 100% asleep no I'm
actually what just
happened I just saw you no what just
what just
happened no what what
really now what actually what actually
just happened was I realized that I'm
looking at you in the computer and not
in the L in the hole I'm doing the same
thing and I was like am I supposed to no
just at me this is the big quarantine
pickle are we supposed to look at the
screen am I supposed to look in the
hole
that's uh I'm looking I'm the hole
doesn't exist to me okay cuz I was like
oh my God I must look being so rude cuz
I'm not looking I'm looking at you but
not looking like in your how do you make
eye contact through a fucking machine
you can't it's fine I'm looking at you
in the screen the ey Lin's going to be
off no one cares going love it we're g
to yeah so another question is what is
it like having like a signature lip like
you have a signature color it's your
color um well I actually have uh in case
I needed a little reapplication while we
were talking I brought my new my current
fave which is the Sephora Rouge lip tint
oh stain okay a I love a stain I love a
stain love a
stain I like a lip color that looks like
mine but a little deeper so I don't know
if I think it might be my my color in
plus plus I'm very pale so everything
looks like I have a a real serious lip
on did you ever because for the like you
had that was it the brand that you wore
Jesus yeah holy shit how do you remember
that I I have a weirdly good memory
about oh my God yeah tart it's a a a
crayon yeah it was like tart it was not
like brick or whatever it was called and
uh was there every time you were just
like I don't want to fucking like yeah
every goddamn week I was like I can't
fucking take it anymore do you know like
obviously I'm I'm so grateful for two BR
girls I'm so grateful to have had a show
on that long but
I wore the same nail polish that's right
that blue three
seasons and the same exact makeup for
all six seasons and I mean I think there
were a couple of times where I had like
a red lip in season six right right
right right but Michael Patrick King was
like very like Beth changed her look up
a lot and cut her hair and like did he
was like you always have to look the
same and I was like that's fine like
don't give it like that that's but then
it was like I can't physically fucking
take this color anymore yeah it was it
was interesting though because didn't
you just have that on when we shot it
yeah well it was a Wet n Wild color it
was like 99 Cents and I was like oh this
matches like the my bracelet yeah like
it oh the copper bracet copper turquoise
that I also never changed any of my um
jewelry whatever it's like oh thought I
had to wear jewelry my life is so
hard but that's what we're doing here
like no one I'm
complaining I now
when now exactly yeah so yeah it was it
was I actually I was going through some
of my old stuff and I found so many like
old pictures from my youth in that time
and I found my cup of nail polishes wow
I had three of them because I kept being
scared that they they'd stop selling
that color and then someone would shoot
me I think people don't oh that's so
interesting I think people sometimes
don't know but I think I'm finding with
this podcast people really care about
these this minutia of when you pick a
look you got to stick to it or pick a
character like I was uh I remember
watching that movie the Revenant where
Leonard DiCaprio got attacked by the
bear the Bear show the bear the Bear
show the bear I'm 100 I haven't seen the
the C the covant the reeven it's porn
with a bear I mean it's just it's lard
DiCaprio and Tom Hardy just being hot oh
Tom hard's in it yes all right yes yes
add to cart just to turn the volume off
that's right have some wine
mute and so uh so he uh Leonardo Caprio
is like like not wearing a shirt oh not
wearing gloves he's wearing a like a fur
and then no gloves and they shot for $10
months and the director was like you
sure you don't want to wear gloves and
he was like no he wouldn't have gloves
he would be you know like cutting he'd
have to be 10 months of being they shot
literally in like up like Northern
Canada this is a 10mon shoot it was a
10mon shoot cuz they he only shot with
natural sunlight is this Lord of the
Ring I know totally and why can't you
just all right he's like my biggest
regret as an actor is not just going oh
the character would be wearing gloves so
that I the actor can wear gloves for 10
months God you know yeah that's like you
with that lipstick and that nail polish
stand up for himself like I did with my
ankle I'm done you DiCaprio could learn
a thing or two from me I do not
disagree so yeah I I I want to talk more
about how scared I was to ask you to do
this because I really was because you
and I are very similar I I I don't like
you don't like doing things I don't like
doing anything that requires
energy or being seen I'm very shy um no
I think I just you are very shy people
don't know that you are very shy how do
you know that because I know you that's
so weird that you know that of course I
know I've known you for like a deod a
deod I know but I yeah and you also just
don't you see right through bullshit
because I have to pretend I'm uh an
extrovert a lot because yeah well
because how would you survive
correct correct spit by the way thank
God we're not in the same room a a speck
of my saliva just went right into I
would just have a full Co droplet in my
eyelid no we're going to do round two of
this in person when this is 100% I'm
going to make you um but yeah yeah you
you are very shy and um contemplative
and you think about stuff a lot well I
think it's hard for people to believe
that someone who is confident in what
they do can also be shy socially you
know or yes actors performers they
expect us even on our off time like I
don't I I do I I figure out a way to do
talk shows I I I I oh that is hard but
it feels like work to me it should it it
it is I had a conversation named up
named up with um at your house with
Chelsea Handler a long time ago cuz she
was asking like she was like why won't
you do my show so chel I was like I
can't I was like first of all I'm
sweating why did you say that to me um I
was told no one would ever tell you that
but I I'm over it now but it's a thing
where it's like a a to be
you in a way that's an
entertainment setting on your real
personality for me used to send me into
this like Cyclone of panic and like on I
just couldn't I couldn't put my
personality into a space that I felt was
funny and like cute or whatever like I
couldn't I couldn't figure out how to do
it I'm like that too I'm like am I doing
standup am I yeah like what is this what
am I selling also am I flirting with you
like I I don't don't know what I'm doing
here like it's a it's weird some people
and I told her that and she was like oh
I get it and then I did her show like a
year later and I was fine yeah and I can
I understand how to do it now but it's a
weird thing for any human and it's also
like okay I have to tell a story where
either I sound stupid or I make fun of
someone else like it's I really I really
struggle with doings and then you have
like someone else on that you're like
I'm good at making fun of myself I'm
good at making fun of other people I can
make fun of the host because I know you
know Jimmy Fallon or whoever they're
like or Letterman was always amazing at
that like he's a comic he could get it
but you're on with like someone from a
reality show and you're like am I
laughing I haven't done that many so I
haven't I haven't I don't think I I
actually don't remember honestly yeah I
don't remember most of my
life I can really only
handle the the last month of things it's
all been an outof Body Experience yeah
and so what's going on with
dollface oh dollface is great uh season
two I is mostly all written I think by
now but it will be Golden Girls because
you guys will be 40 by the time you
actually shoot it we're all
65 um it's great we're picked up for
second season when we shoot it nobody
knows
um but I mean the writers are still
writing and I get these emails like the
notes emails I'm like oh that's hello
what are you guys doing you guys oh this
isn't the recipe exchange have you
gotten that no oh okay I need to say
this needs to stop what the recipe
exchange and the coid time like chain
lettering don't do it wow see I've
gotten a few different like chain
letteres like things like send this to
the first person on the list and then
send it back to me and then send it to
20 of your friends I'm like first of all
I don't have 20s 20 friends in what
world who has 20 friends no one
Psychopaths I don't know what you want
I'm not doing this this is a vacation
this is sad vacation time we're on
vacation and we're sad no one's having a
good time I don't want to do this I did
it one time and then I said I'm not
affording this to anyone however here is
my favorite
recipe and here's what I'll say I've
I've been noticing and this is something
I love so much about you because you
have managed to be so so successful so I
mean I I know that you probably don't
know that you're famous because you
don't go outside so I'm getting too many
compliments in this podast I don't I'm
I'm just as upset about it as you are
pains me to say all this okay oh God
sweating sweating um but you're also so
down to earth like you and I have never
had a conversation where I'm like oh
well she turned it happened like the
shoe dropped on cat like she was the
most salt of the earth like I remember
at the first taping of two BR girls like
your parents were there like it was just
like you're just like so I hate when
people say normal cuz there's no such
thing and I don't feel like that's true
but you're so idio syncratic and unique
and um such an like beautiful odity what
like the ones in case and glass put
myself under a clo but you are just so
like clear on who you are self-aware and
you have such like I've always had
perspective and I and and there's a lot
of people I've met that had it and then
they lost it a lot of people that never
had it a lot of you know people that
never had it went to therapy got it a
lot of people that a pandemic had to
happen for them to get it there's a lot
of iterations right but I'm seeing a lot
of celebrities that are very out of
touch on social media that are like
posting recipes yes oh I'm glad we're
talking about this we might have to cut
some of it out because I'm ready to talk
some shit dude the business is over I
there's no Bridges to burn i g to say
what I want I don't care this is our
career now you're gonna start a podcast
and you never have to leave your house
again done in the cookbook space dude
I'm oh you would have you should do a
cooking thing you'd be amazing at that H
god um but I'm seeing first of all I'm
seeing a lot of celebrities like tell
people what to do with their kids
they're like here's some ideas of things
to do with your kids like play blocks do
coloring books everyone's like bitch we
always hang out with our kids yeah we
congrats welcome to being a par a Paran
every weekend is shelter and place for
us we're all I me I don't have kids but
I remember the thing when you're a kid
and you play with blocks like this isn't
a this isn't a new thing it's funny to
have celebrities who normally have
nannies taking care of their kids
be like okay so here's some things to do
with your kids everyone's like we know
what to do with our kids n PS I was
homeschooled my entire childhood this
must be wild for you it's not a big
fucking de I'm sorry it's not a big
goddamn deal to drive I'm gonna get
crucified for this but you don't have to
D if I listen I thought about when I one
day have a child I'm not taking that kid
to a school germ Festival f no a
germs B other kids being mean like
you're the perfect example of why kids
not that we needed to make this argument
but I know that I think I was like
trying to and Chris Rock did a great
joke about sona's last special about how
kids need to be bullied it's a funny
take like it builds character you're the
perfect example of like no they don't
they don't look I managed to get bullied
while being homeschooled like it'll
happen don't worry by oh yeah by other
homeschool kids man like they'll find
you bitch wait is there like a
homeschool like homecoming a hes school
coming okay I so I went to twice a week
I did I helped out with younger kids one
day a week for a while which was great
they were really cute and sweet and then
I went to like a
homeschool class with like 10 other
homeschooled kids like once or twice a
week and it was hell it was hell um I
mean I met some of some great I mean
most of them were great but I did manage
to get bullied really bad by this by one
and then two girls what were their
angle um I still don't
know one was I remember her first and
last name of course like that this is
and this is why I my argument for
homeschooling is because when your brain
is developing and you're little these
things that don't seem like a thing can
haunt this child like forever and like
these moments become enormous to them
like as they age like I I've been called
some crazy shit I don't care I think
about what this little girl did to me
like a lot when I was like nine and I I
remember of all the things that happened
to me in my childhood like out growing
up in alcoholic home abuse like narciss
all this stuff everyone's gone through
all it right and uh the most traumatic
childhood memory I have is showing up to
a new school in the wrong uniform Oh
see it really like it really fucks with
not having like my permission slip
signed for the field trip and I couldn't
go I mean it's like but don't you
remember these moments into adulthood
and they don't seem like a big deal like
when I say this to you now I'm like I
can't believe that was a thing but when
you're a kid it is when you only have a
couple years of Consciousness under your
belt and you're defining yourself as a
human and when shame comes in oh God
like that feeling is it's the worst
feeling in the world for a kid is shame
so you just spend your whole life going
how do I avoid that feeling again so
it's con
yeah if your mle is activated it's a
trauma kids don't need it I'm sorry like
they'll get it yeah you know you'll get
to it I don't think they need it when
they're little and innocent I just don't
think but I again I'm not a parent I
don't know anything yeah and I think
that for a lot of people what we're also
realizing right now is for a lot of
people school's just a babysitter like
we just I have to drop my kids somewhere
for you know like I mean for me I just
don't want to have to drive somewhere
twice a day the amount them off pick
them up come on and then I remember my
when I lived in Virginia for a while
like my um aunts had like a truck and
when you're a kid you just want the same
as everything else you don't it doesn't
it's not a matter of like fancy car
Fancy Shoes it's just you it's just you
want to fit in you know like when I was
a kid everyone had the the pumps they
were um uh shoes that you could blow up
Jordans but they could blow up there was
like a little pump in the front yeah the
little the little yeah the little thing
isn't isn't that an Air Jordan am I an
idiot I no I'm an idiot cuz I think they
were called pumps oh what yeah so
they'll they'll let us know in the
comments don't worry um and uh and I
went to school and no one had the
everyone had the pumps and I didn't have
the pumps and it was like it was just
like such a weird trauma to just like
not have to be able to fit in and I
remember my aunt had a truck everyone
else had a car I used to make my aunt
drop me off like half a mile away from
school I would walk to like it was just
like it's just so crazy the it's hunting
you even now now even now yes the
gymnastics so I was so painfully shy uh
I'm sure you understand that about me
because now I'm an actor um I was
painfully shy and terrified to talk in
front of the other kids but there was
like a creative writing thing and you
could write whatever and of course um I
had a pet rabbit at the time of course
you did all of my creative writing was
just about the rabbit because I was too
I was I love to write but I was too
embarrassed to
like read something I'd really written
in front of these fucking assholes
right like I'll just write some bullshit
about my rabbit and I was always reading
some stuff about my rabbit my pet rabbit
and then
we H one day I come into this home
school place and we all had like a cubby
where we could put our bag and
whatnot and in my
cubby was a gray stuffed animal
rabbit that these two girls had stabbed
with scissors and covered in fake
blood cuz I had a gray rabbit I
literally started crying that is that
I'm sorry that is truly the most
upsetting thing I've ever heard oh no
that is like on some Heather shit that
is wild I'm sorry to make you cry those
children are for sure there's in jail
currently they're assholes and that was
one thing and then they were like
waiting to see what I was going to do
they were like hiding and watching me
this is so dark this is like fucking
Lord of The Fly shit yeah I know and I
knew they were watching me and so I was
like
and I like pushed it closed and I like
got myself and you know and I went and
of course I was wearing like overalls
and a fucking hen
shirt and then put my slot bracelet on
and I got out of there yeah I a yo-yo
like how was that kid and they started
doing this thing to me this is also
really fucked up actually maybe this is
bad they would wait till I went to the
bathroom to like pee they'd go in after
me and dump red food coloring in the
toilet and then they'd come out and tell
everyone that I had like my period all
over the
place this is how crazy is that really
upsetting I know and remember there are
like 10 kids in this thing there's not
that many kids like this isn't the
school monsters I know so that is pretty
bad actually but and then one of them
like tried to fight me and I was like
we're in
Pennsylvania like we're in we're by a
creek can we just stop with this let's
just stop so I'm GNA ask you a question
because I think you and I are similar in
this way and I had a lot of sort of
stuff like this as a kid with with girls
like I'm really careful with the people
I let in my life like friendships now
like now yeah certainly should I'm
curious like what are your red flags for
like a new person letting a new person
in your
life
uh you know because we have to vet
people it's hard because sometimes
especially when you meet someone on a
set you're spending so much time
together and you get so close and it's
sort of like you know yeah I don't have
I don't know if I have like things
specific things I feel like I have a
good sense good gut gut yeah like I I've
always been able to tell I think I look
for things instead of like seeing things
that are not a good idea like it's
pretty obvious when somebody is like
just recording everything or like taking
themselves all the time yep or like you
know I don't I don't want to girls and
dudes like I don't I'm not meaning this
isn't just a girl thing but like when
yeah that fine that's a red flag like
constant selfies and constant like
instagramming and constant like yeah
looking for like the
opportunity yeah that's my thing is like
I get at some point not about being with
me just in general like life like yes
not being able to like be in the moment
living your life for public consumption
that is a red flag for me cuz it makes
me anxious and it makes me feel like I'm
not doing enough or or maybe I see some
of myself in it and it's I'm repelled by
it cuz it holds up a mirror to the
things I don't like about myself or
whatever it is but I definitely you know
and Dan Levy when he came on the podcast
and I were talking about this of like if
you take a picture of us and don't and
and what I all I need is cool to post a
text that just says cool to post oh my
God I would NE I would never post
something without asking people people
first I have face tuned other
people there is a very famous actress
let's see if you guys can guess it in
the comments you're never going to she's
famous in like a weird way who every one
of her photos is a selfie of her like on
set and with without missing one every
single photo there's someone in the
background that doesn't know they're in
the photo who's
like who's like looking reading who
looks like absolute shit in the
background I not into it I she looks
amazing and there's like the script
supervisor in the background
like it's oh God like the fact that you
cannot even see beyond yourself and
wouldn't ask permission from these
people is just so wild to me so that to
me is that that is a big one it's a
small thing that means a lot yeah I mean
I don't I
don't I don't know I can just feel I can
just feel when I meet someone who who's
like a real person yeah it doesn't
always happen which is why I can
immediately tell yeah um you know you
can kind of tell when someone's putting
on their like yep work face and that's
fine we all do it a big one like yeah
Brenda Song yeah one of my dearest
friends yeah sweetest but I I knew like
you I just knew like we kind of looked
each other like okay here we go yep here
we I'm gonna tell you everything about
me you're gonna tell me everything about
you I'm going tell you every secret I've
ever had and that's how it is and like
cuz I'm obsessed with making new old
friends you know because sometimes we
have to I'm finally at the point in my
life where I realize like oh some
friendships dissolve like this is the
first time in my life I've ever gone
like oh you outgrow someone or you grow
in different directions so in my head it
was always like no you have best friends
and you keep them forever and it's like
oh I just learned that that's not
necessarily true so I am obsessed with
like how to make new old friends um and
oh that's really good that's really good
and I think one of the things I noticed
where I was like okay you're going to be
a new old friend if when I'm around you
I'm funnier but I don't think I have to
be there it is yeah if you don't feel
like you have to do stuff for you I can
be boring we can it's so funny me and um
this friend of mine who actually used
she used to open for me Melissa via seor
uh and we've now become like you know
good friends after sort of like you know
she went to New York for SNL and came
back and the it was just kind of weird
cuz she used to open for me and that's
always like a sort of oh yeah weird
thing and now we're you know obviously
equals and um she uh came over and we
like went for a hike together and didn't
talk for like 20 minutes H heaven on
Earth like oh my God we were just like
laid by the pool and like did we weren't
making no Small Talk none the the dream
the dream I was like if I can just sit
here and be quiet with you yeah isn't
that the thing where they're like you
should marry the person you can like
read a book with or whatever is that a
thing yes well yes I think I just want
to marry someone who can read period
that's that's my bar that's my bottom
line the bar has been lowered to just
reading just literate all right literate
it's all I pretty much ask then do I
have the man for
you it's my
nephew it's my kindall
yeah I mean I just I really get thrown
about all that stuff I mean when it
because I'm now going to be dating again
ah God why God I mean I don't have to
but I'm how do we do the okay because I
don't I don't I'm not a person so how do
you date now that you can't be with
people this is a thing right well here's
what I'll say I think there is something
to be said for the best relationships
I've ever had which were great and just
ended for reasons that you know nothing
to do with it I think to date long
distance first or date virtually is not
only going to have to be the future
because of the invisible murders but
also a great way to get to know people
without the passion and neurology and
sex stuff clouding it up I mean you know
you've seen me in some weird
relationships I have you've seen me I
mean we we all we've all we but I'm
saying there have been plenty of people
who
that the sexual chemistry clouded my
judgment around the person's character
and I realized I was falling in love
with a lot of people before I knew
them it takes my mom always says it
takes three years to actually know a
person that is correct I agree 100 yeah
I've had more than three therapists tell
me
that all right Benton kick it off kick
it off this is door Dash let me tell you
about door Dash let me tell you
something I enjoy they bring those wings
right to my door wings I had wings with
a little bit of uh a little bit of ranch
dressing delivered right to me and I had
myself a little quarantine party you
just went to Door Dash and said wangs
yeah I said I want wangs and they said
we're on it delivered wangs delivered
fast fresh hot and wonderful right to my
door brings your food right away you
went to the door Dash app chose wangs
and your food was left safely outside
your door germ free virus free y
invisible murderers free because of the
new contactless Delivery drop off
setting I mean door Dash is the only way
to I've eaten yeah the only reason I'm
alive at this point in they tell me when
they're on their way they let me know if
anything is is there's trouble at the
restaurant do you want blue cheese too I
was like absolutely they brought it to
me they check in all your food is there
I'm sorry to slam other services that
aren't door Dash but sometimes you get
your food and only half of it is there
and you're like how am I supposed to
have my mango sticky
rice yeah door Dash without my pad tie
ruined my whole night very easy they're
very responsible very nice uh they have
all your favorite restaurants Chipotle
Wendy's Cheesecake Factory many of your
favorite local restaurants are still
open order from them if you can let's
keep these restaurants in business let's
keep these people employed go to the
door Dash app select your favorite local
restaurant your food will be left at
your door germ free door Dash deliveries
are now uh contactless to keep
communities we operate in safe and right
now our listeners can get $5 off their
first order of $15 or more and zero
delivery fees for their first month when
you download the door Dash app and enter
the code Whitney I just love I just love
the word door Dash just so fun good
compound word yeah that's $5 off your
first order and zero delivery fees for a
month when you download the door Dash
app at the App Store and you enter the
code Whitney who's Whitney you don't
forget that code Whitney for $5 off your
first order with door Dash
you want to thrive you got to eat good
Jesus I wasn't ready you want to thrive
you have to eat good you know who makes
that easy Thrive stop yelling at me I'm
excited so my this company has solved
like a major problem for me which is
that there's a lot of things I do not
eat because I have allergies I get
migraines I try not to eat gluten I try
not to eat wheat I try to eat I don't
eat chemicals I try not to eat a lot of
animal products solve big problems for
me too you know what I hate going to the
grocery store for you I feel like every
time I go to the grocer I have to read
the ingredients like it's impossible to
know what you're eating Thrive Market
solve this problem okay they give me all
of the stuff that I actually eat you do
this like paid membership thing uh that
provides a free one for someone in need
like a low-income family teacher veteran
or first responder um but so this is
also a good company and your karma is
set and you're a benevolent if you use
Thrive but here's the deal what it does
is Thrive Market tailors to over 70
different kinds of diets hold on I feel
like we should start this over I'm sorry
I didn't understand this whole paid
membership like uh hold on let me
describe the company and then say the
paid membership I'm sorry can we start
over or or just start from the him
saying it makes my life a lot easier or
whatever okay let me explain what Thrive
Market does it tailors to 70 different
kinds of diets paleo keto plant-based
you're vegan you don't want gluten
whatever it is and then it delivers you
the highest quality organic and non GMO
food they off also offer clean Beauty
and bath products cuz you know I'm that
beach pet Staples pet Staples um so you
can get your uh pet food I have a dog
that's like has like bladder Crystal so
I have to order a specific kind of food
for him I have one that has a heart
condition so she's not like she can't
have beans or lentils so I have to have
a different food for her but I hate
going to the store and having to sit
there and read the ingredients for 40
minutes so what they do is you just put
in all the restrictions and then they
only show you the products that are for
you that are for you they got ethical
meat clean wine non-toxic cleaning
products ethical meat sustainable
Seafood clean Wine and More um I can
only do clean wine and when I freaking
go sorry freaking I tried to say
freaking and it sounded like a bad word
it just makes me so mad when I have to
go to the wine store or like the wine
the grocery store what do you call it
the ventor I don't know the V uh and I
go in and I'm like I just need the non
GMO wine cuz I get such bad migraines
but don't show me just don't show me any
of the ones I can't drink I don't even
want to see them you know yeah cuz then
you going to want them then I'm going to
want them because I'm going to fall in
love with the sticker so my thing is
just show me the clean wines because I
can only have those clean wines and
dirty
martini uh Thrive Market is super easy
to use too the shopping experience was
really simple went on put in all the
things you wanted you needed you liked
you love well you just go in and you say
like I don't want gluten I want paleo I
want I love crackers um things like that
I have a dog this is what my dog can eat
and they just show you that in a little
list you click on what you want and then
it's yours I'm saving 25 to 50% off
traditional retail prices love that and
their carbon neutral shipping is free on
orders over
$49 you also can um uh which is what we
did a Thrive Market member which is a
paid membership where you're also going
to provide one for someone in need like
a low income family teacher veteran
first responder so you also get to get
that good karma in addition to that good
food food and sustenance not only do I
feel good about getting a deal on my
favorite clean organic products I also
feel great about helping to support the
families that need it most I'm beautiful
on the outside and on the inside and
they're fast you're getting your
groceries on time you're not waiting for
ever for them like they're showing up
that's right that's right uh and they um
yeah because a lot of the places right
now they're just overwhelmed I'm not I'm
not going to name names but I'm only
using Thrive uh try Thrive Market to
become a member risk-free go to
thrivemarket.com
good for you join today and you're going
to get up to $20 in sh shopping credit
towards your first order again this is
where you're going to get all your
Healthy yummy delicious food
thrivemarket.com
good for you start your risk-free
membership get up to $20 first towards
your first order first year towards
order towards your first order
thrivemarket.com
good for you this is such a game Cher
for
groceries love it yes Whitney approved
and I hate everything I hate going to
the freaking grocery store I don't want
to see all the goddamn options cuz I'm
going to want everything and then I'm
going to get it home I'm going to
realize it's full of chalk full of
gluten and r random fucking shit I don't
want thrive thrive Market Thrive got got
to thrive such a great name too three
years I don't know why well cuz I feel
like that's the amount of time you're
going to see someone at their best at
their worst you're going to go through a
death you're going to go through a
sickness you're going to go through a
delayed flight you're going to go
through a c you know like you're going
to travel together you're going to go
through a friend's marriage a friend's
divorce like you're going to see them in
every scenario that's a short marriage I
don't it
was I just revealed so much about myself
you know cuz like within the first two
months someone them get married and then
divorc two months later and they'll have
a bad breakup and she didn't sign a
prenup so it's going to be a whole
fucking nightmare um that was a warshock
test I failed but like you're going to
see them in a lot of different scenarios
like yeah I remember I was madly in love
with someone and then I but I realized
later the relationship depended on me
being very high functioning and strong
and uh independent in a lot of ways
emotionally and physically and the
second I I got like strep I got like
sick Oh all fell apart as soon as I
really I needed
something and then he was like I I can't
I don't know what this is like oh this
is a test this is a dating test when you
get sick it's a big test because I won't
say who but I remember I a boyfriend
that I'm not not with anymore I was the
funny now I was on the phone with him
and I had eaten some Moz ball soup that
was
not good anymore maybe I don't know sour
matah well I had just ordered it so have
a bat in it by any chance it didn't what
did it have a bat in it God oh yes it
did it was bad
[Laughter]
Rob I drank some bad broth and then I
was on the
phone and I was like oh I was in bed on
the phone and I stood up I was like oh I
feel kind of hot and you know that's the
first that's the first step yes I was
like oh I feel kind of hot and I got up
to turn my air on and I sat back down I
was like uh and he was talking about
something my old place had I was sitting
on the bed it had a door to the bathroom
oh no right know pretty close to the bed
I was sitting there and I just felt the
the cold the VAP you got the vapers to
take over me and I was like woo and he
was just BL BL BL like talking about
whatever no
idea and I projectile vomited I've never
done this in my life through the open
door into the bathroom thank God I mean
if that door was closed it would be a
whole other story just thre like a like
a rocket
ship and I hung up cuz I was like he
can't hear
this oh fuck oh
fuck he kept calling and I was like oh
like crawling into the I was like fully
like passing out and all I could think
of was I had to get the door closed so
my cat didn't go in and like get K call
prints of vomit all over the house I'm
like crawling in cuz now I'm completely
like I'm I'm I'm Consciousness in now
get into the bathroom and close the door
so it's me alone with my vomit in the
bathroom and I call him back and I'm
like I don't feel like when I'm sick I'm
not one of those strong strong nor
should you be I'm going to die I'm gonna
die and I'm upset also let me just pause
vomiting I hadn't vomited in a while I
vomited like four months ago it's so
violent it's it's the worst as my friend
Kevin Christie puts it so elegantly he
goes you're screaming into a
toilet you're
like like it it's possessed you can't
believe what's happening you can't
believe how little control you have your
body is like doing something without you
without you without your permission
you're on you're along for the ride you
have nothing to do with it
your body's like I'll take it from here
you can just chill thank you ma'am I got
this yeah I I'm going to take it from
here you obviously don't really make
good choices I mean I'm telling I mean
it must have been six feet wow yes yes
and I'm I'm on the floor weeping
immediately I'm terrified worst yeah I'm
like I don't feel so good he's like what
happened I was like I don't know I mean
I'm not exaggerating that's how was and
he was like oh my God I'll be right over
I was like really and he was like yeah
and I was like oh my God this is the
first time anyone's ever get and then he
goes do you think you're
like
contagious I was like what he was like
well do you like think you're like sick
sick like do you think like you have
like a I don't know like a like I don't
know I like maybe I shouldn't actually
like I kind of have a lot to do this
week like
boo and I was like are you fucking
serious boo I was like finally a dude is
going to come and and make me feel
better and be there for me and then two
seconds later it's like actually maybe I
won't and can I tell it's so as you're
saying that and I think this is why
virtual dating is going something like I
once I lose respect for someone it's
over that's the the moment where I just
went like oh I see you completely
differently that is such a revealing
moment but and it went from here too I
was like oh my God this is so great like
he really cares because like I'm not I'm
like literally weeping in my own vomit
and he's going to come like be with me
and
then boof gone not not
happening
ew what a bummer like I've had some of
those moments like I remember one time
was with this guy that I was very into
and I have a pro I'm I'm admitting it I
don't like this about myself but if
someone is I'm I don't like to fight I
know it's a necessary evil in
relationships a lot of it is just sort
of testing you know it's figuring out
boundaries it's figuring out compromises
like I know that good relationships
you're going to have you know some push
and pull H we're human we're emotional
we're sensitive that's the deal but if
someone not good at fighting or elegant
or doesn't make sense or ghost plays a
cheap card I just might I I shut down
and I just fall out of well why would
well as soon as I hear the word bitch
I'm out oh goodbye because I just am
like I'm sure I am a bitch but the fact
that that's but so are you like I use
the word bitch and fights a lot more
than any man ever has well I think it's
just like if once you've gone there
you've lost the argument it's yeah but
that listen I am no expert I am the
wrong person to take advice from about
anything I disagree I was afraid to
fight with any
boyfriend until I was in my 30s because
you were worried about being abandoned
or pushing them away um I don't know but
I was just like fighting is
bad and um my brain said like whatever I
do I want things to be great like I want
I want everything to be good so I and no
fault of the men I was with like I push
down so much for the sake of not
fighting and like I put aside everything
that I felt no matter what it was almost
always because I didn't want to fight
and I didn't realize how you know what a
mistake that was till I was much older
that's and now I'm like I have something
to say excuse me sir shoes off in the
house
remember that thing you said one minute
ago I don't like it and I would like to
talk about it for an
hour and that's it that to me is the
that's how it is now great and if you're
not down see you yeah if here's the
thing a man a lovely man gave me such
good
advice which was if you're not you at
the beginning that's right you're just
going to surprise that person later
that's right when you're tired of it
yeah it's the pushup bra personality so
yeah just like be be and it's really
hard man and it's also first of all it's
also taking me a long time to realize
like it's also just lying yeah just be
just do you at the beginning if you have
enough self-awareness to know who you
are which takes a long time and if you
find yourself pretending if you find
yourself shape-shifting it's not the
right person they're making you feel
insecure they're making you feel judged
you're like I I know that when I start
seeing someone if I feel the need to
like be smart or if I feel the need to
like be like like not go like what does
this mean like if I'm at a restaurant
I'm like what's what's a this pasta
what's that cheese called like if I
can't not know things or if IE if I
pretend I know things I don't know yeah
or I'm too afraid to ask about something
I don't know I'm like this is bad this I
main red flag then I can give you my
main red flag for for relationship BBE
extends to Friendship is if when that
person leaves or I leave that person I
feel relief
oo like I remember the turning point in
in relationships or whatever it is where
they would leave and I'd be like oh
finally like I can be me again not like
fuck them but just like now I feel
relaxed again wow that's such a good one
yeah but and then nothing to do with the
with those people because they they're
not doing anything to you but like for
whatever reason you and them together
stresses you out somehow that you feel
relief when they're gone oh that's such
a good one I also have one this is such
a sad one but uh if I feel like I have
to sleep in
makeup oh been
there been there oh my God that
oh or if I like sleep with like gum in
my mouth or like you can die I know what
are you doing death is way better better
than not being loved by someone I don't
even
like like just the little like that like
tanning well you lost me with the tan
like no I used to do like spray tanning
because I thought that was going to like
put me over the edge to be the love of
his life like that was well we've all
done that I mean come on I know but it
just took me so I look at myself in my
20s and just the rigar roll I put myself
through I used to wake up
at the crack of dawn and put makeup on
back go back and pretend you were
sleeping wake up it's like Mrs
M so dumb it's just all but but it's
just it's so I think important like I
mean not wearing makeup like that is a
huge one for me I find the more that I'm
putting makeup on because they don't
give a shit they have they don't know
when you have makeup they don't know
what makeup is they're like
what like what like the black the black
yeah like yeah the black thanks for
noticing it's just you I don't know who
I'm doing in impression you look
beautiful yesterday you look beautiful
today it's just a like they don't know I
remember one time uh I was with some guy
and I had put on like a full face of
makeup the eyes the we're like going out
and I was like I'm going to put my
lipstick on last because I'm going to
eat something right so I go downstairs
and he's like are you going to put
makeup on are we going to go but it was
like but it was like it made me realize
they only know makeup when it's
lipstick that's true eyes eyeliner eyes
Shadow eyebrow pencil red lipstick
that's all they can see nude lipstick is
you're not wearing any makeup yeah oh
it's so true it's like what God it's so
true who's this for what is all this I
don't know I put makeup on for you well
no for you well that's so I want to
impress you way more than anyone I date
oh you look amazing but we get to do
this for but I just found if your motive
is I'm doing this so this man won't
leave I also think if a
guy if I here's the thing if I ever like
look over at a text if I ever look over
at your phone I already like I I don't
like that yeah oh well the phone is a
whole other you know but but I I come at
it in kind of a weird different way
maybe homeschooled way where like I'm
not afraid if they're going to leave I'm
Afra afid I'm going to leave oh that's
who I am that you're going to get scared
if it gets too no I'm no I think my main
issue with men and this is that I I get
bored oh
God yeah and and there's no for me there
is just no coming back
and and and and maybe that's because uh
I have a like a great older brother and
I love my older brother and he's there
for me and I have a you know a strong
male presence yeah but I don't I'm
worried that I'm piecing out cu I think
you also have a very full life in terms
of your friendships like you have very
good friendships you're getting your
internal needs met in healthy ways
you're not you don't I have a small a
very small amount of of people I care
about yeah so it's not I mean to me I'm
never lonier than when I'm with 30
people that I'm like acquaint with you
know what I mean my three close friends
that I feel like are sisters like that
to me when I'm full and my heart is full
that's when a relationship becomes like
like it has to be additive like you have
to bring something to table cuz I'm
already full like my cup's full and you
and I have this much energy for things
she's holding up like a like a wine
glass for people just listening this is
It's a cup it's like a mug it's a half a
cup okay it's two tablespoons it's like
a mug you would find on Etsy that says
don't talk to me before I've had my
coffee size it's an espresso
mug but I also think that like sometimes
we over pathologize ourselves in terms
of this like you know I've had for so
long people tell me like well you're
afraid of intimacy and I was like I
guess I'm afraid of intimacy and then I
was like no I just don't want to date
you yeah like there you know what why is
this my fault a lot of times it's really
simple and I sound like an saying like I
get bored but it's that's it I'm not
afraid of this I'm not afraid of this
I'm not like avoiding this I just get
bored man and the right person you won't
right 100% or or you'll go I'm bored but
I still want to do this like I look
forward to being bored in a way that
makes me happy and chill I don't even
need to be happy all the time I just
need to be fucking chill and it's I it
bro the great writer
D that's okay by the way the hottest
thing and a guy has ever done I was
walking up to a Starbucks that was right
next to a Panda Express and there were
three guys back when we got to go out to
Panda Express and stores member think
where this could be M outside and there
were three guys sitting around this um
table and like you know when you're like
right about to walk by a group of guys
you always have this thing in your head
that's like H they're going to you know
it's just always a thing right I just
crossed the street but yeah I just start
crying um and so I'll like pick a wedgie
just to get him to like I'll just like
walk by just fart just just get rid of
the the the vibe right away but I walk
up and I and you know you always clock
you're like okay these guys are kind of
hot like I'm just going to walk by and
like whatever and uh this guy just
looked at me and went what's up bro oh
shit like the hottest thing that's ever
happened to me it was cuz I it just
threw me oh it that's great and I'm
still talking about it you look this is
the opposite of childhood bullying I I
talked about I've talked about it for
like years I've been like what does it
mean when I called on my guy friends I
was like what does it mean when you call
a girl it was like he was obviously just
fucking with you and knew exactly how to
just throw you off what up bro go where
what's he doing like I don't know I'm I
need to post on misconnections on
Craigslist
um but I think that Ryder Ryder Doyle
he's got a show on Netflix called
bonding and I remember one time I was in
a really toxic relationship and I was
like that annoying friend that it's all
I was talking about this was back when I
thought the more you complained about
something the better it would go like I
just thought if you complained enough
you're saying that doesn't go well if
you just complained enough the situation
would change um uh I didn't know a lot
about science back then and I was
talking about it and I was like in this
and then he does this and then he
doesn't call me back and then he'll come
over without I was just go and he just
looks at me and he goes is it worth it
like is this all worth it and it was and
he was like if the answer is yes we we
love you and we'll support you but I
just I had never thought about that
before I never thought like okay I'm
bored but like this is worth it it's
going to be right when it's worth it
yeah and also like I I I but maybe
that's not that's not a thing to say is
and also I realized something else which
is like there is no such thing as like a
reason for them not to call you or text
you or any there's no reason at all that
exists like there are trauma doctors who
have kids in a marriage like there is no
such thing no such thing as a reason
they can't talk to you doesn't exist
they're busy no they're not no but like
what if fucking busy what if their phone
is doing something weird they got your
text they got your text he maybe didn't
get it yet maybe do check it it went
through he's not like a phone guy no he
is a phone guy but he lives like up in
like the hills and like he might have
reception he has a dish end of story and
you know what he might be afraid of
getting
hurt
that's so
good the gender that literally there's
no man afraid of getting hurtt
gets on a skateboard and just goes down
a hill with no helmet no man in the
world's afraid of getting hurt I don't
give a fuck every everyone who gets hurt
is a dude in general like they sign up
for I mean go to any YouTube video men
are not afraid of getting hurt they're
not afraid of getting hurt in any way
they if they want to they will I
literally like because of you know the
quarantine kids can't go to school every
time I go outside my house that my
neighborhood kids are doing some the I
saw them in a grocery cart like they
were in a grocery cart just going down a
dirt Hill like they're just like so that
sounds kind of great I I wish I could do
that right and then I'm the annoying
neighbor that's like you're going to
clog up the emergency rooms with your
broken ankles like get off my lawn you
know but that's right that uh or he's
afraid of getting hurt no maybe he likes
you too much no he likes you too much to
much that's not a thing that's not real
that's not real and I found my when I
was going through my shit and I found
like my nail polish and cute pictures of
us and stuff I also found all of my
journals and now we will have a reading
of them I actually do have one you
really so
funny I didn't plan on doing a reading
but I had it in my room because I was
like I have to fucking read this because
I i' I've learned a lot about dudes
since then and it's just full of of like
why didn't he like he said he was going
to call me back but he like didn't call
me back and I just don't know should I
email him or should I just like act cool
and this just all this like
heartbreaking
stuff and like it's just I'm sick of it
I wish I could go back and time and just
be like he he's he doesn't want to and
also he doesn't want to and like that's
okay there's people that it's fine don't
like cats there's people that don't like
puppies there's people that you know
what I mean like it took me well those
people are San that's I mean when I when
I and it's not a you don't have to
reject yourself when you like he's not
into this like yeah cuz I'm fucking
awesome and I'm an equal and he can't
hand like it doesn't have to be you know
something that is wrong with you if he
doesn't like you it's not a failure on
your part it's a failure on their part
yeah and it's just it's also like maybe
do you like H it's also like I wish I
asked myself like do you like him this
much it doesn't matter no no no I like
or do you want him to like you I've
never even I didn't even Explore that I
don't it doesn't even matter if I like
him or not I need his validation and
approval and I need another name drop oh
here we go carrat top it's a big one
Natalie Portman yeah said to me when I
was in my early 20s she was like when
you are ready for a nice guy there will
be one
there
but H like what do you mean a nice guy
yeah what is that a oxy yeah what are
you talking about and she was like when
you realize how great you are you're not
going to be this upset all the time but
I think that like you know we also the
same way and I'm I'll speak for myself
and not you the same way we say like
guys in their 20s want to like sleep
with a lot of women and like get stuff
out of their system I think for me in my
20s I also wanted to like date a lot of
like broken people to get that you know
the way a guy wants to see like a bunch
of boobs I also wanted a bunch of like
dramatic adrenaline filled drama filled
relationships like I might have been
using them the same way they were using
me you know like no no one at that age
knows anything anyway like I didn't know
anything I was unconscious like I I mean
it was like I thought there was
something sexy about like screaming in
the rain and like checking my phone 50
times it's it was just like a very uh
complicated like video game I'm like is
he going to respond now it's a gambling
you know I get when you look at people
in Vegas just gambling I'm like oh
that's what I did in my 20s just with my
heart yeah I I don't know what I was
doing I it was just kind of like I guess
it's kind of the opposite but I was like
I just want to find the one immediately
I don't want to date I don't want to
sleep with anybody I just want to find
the man I'm G to marry and I want to be
done and so every time I met a guy I was
just like yep is it you yes and and then
when it wasn't I was like bye stop
wasting my time and I think that might
be now that we're saying I'm 22 stop
wasting my time I don't have time for
this I only have 80 more years on the
clock but maybe that's why now I'm
piecing it together maybe that's why I
get quote unquote bored is because I'm
like maybe this isn't the maybe this
isn't it I gotta go that's interesting
and I and I think that you know I do
sometimes have hot takes when I come in
in defense of of men on this kind of
stuff cuz we have been conditioned to
look at men that objectify men the same
way they've been taught to kind of
objectify us physically we've been
taught to objectify them emotionally are
you a husband or not whereas a man might
look at a woman and go like are you a 10
or not you know and it's from it's from
the movies I mean in my case yes it's
from fairy tales and movies and this and
books 100% I mean I didn't I didn't go
to high school I didn't know what boys
were really like or whatever I just knew
like love stories and things that I was
reading in the 1800s you know for story
Toms I was consuming every week so I was
looking for that which isn't but I think
I think that like you know it took me so
long to realize what you just said was
that's what I was doing I would meet a
guy and go okay you're my husband this
guy that just like came up to me at a
bar who kind of just wanted to like
flirt and I'm like are you my husband or
are you the father of my kids or not and
they're just like that's right yeah like
just like and there's no way they could
ever live up to the standard which I
hadn't even fully fleshed out anyway I
didn't even know what right I was
looking for what I was looking for I was
in this casting call for a role that
wasn't written yet you know right and
holding the same way I wouldn't want a
guy to hold me to Impossible physical
standard I'm holding them to this
impossible emotional standard like I
remember I used to get so many fights
with um this one guy was dating
everything he would do and it's right
when I turned like 32 I want to say
maybe that's when the biology started to
kick in he would like put milk in his
coffee in that one day and then the next
day he like wouldn't put milk in I be
like so you just milk one day no milk
the other day so is this just how it's
going to be that is weird it's very it's
very weird we might have been like out
of milk though I have a thing about this
actually and I want to hear the rest of
your story first though well no I was
just gonna say everything meant you're G
to be a bad father but
well I'm I'm on your side
here like well no he was going to be a
bad father but not cuz of the milk it
was for like a inconsistent a very well
just like who but then you could also
make the argument you're so flexible
you're going to be a greata you
sometimes you'll have milk if it's there
and you won't if you're not you're not
an addict you're not I know rigid like
it could go either way I don't know I
think you're right I don't know I feel
this I do the same I find that very
suspicious I you have coffee different
different ways I have coffee the same
way every 20 years day 20 years same way
20 years but what happen happens if you
what happens if you're out of your oat
milk not going to drink coffee then I'll
drink something else so if we don't have
oat milk you're just not going to drink
coffee at all and get a
headache I'll drink tea I can't drink
coffee if it's not the way I like
it well that so we're at an
impact well now I'm bored now I'm we're
breaking up now I'm bored and you're not
worth it that's right I I I find it
weird not to be this guy but I am when
when someone has are you drinking black
coffee I'm about to disl Coffee I no I'm
drinking coffee with it's
got truly hunks oh god of like of like
chocolate um coconut powder oh that
sounds good all right that's fine it's
delicious but I didn't have time to like
mix it it's fine yeah when someone
drinks black
coffee I don't how was your time in
prison yeah there's also been a there is
an
article that says like people who drink
black coffee are like um
murderers there's something about
there's there's a great article about
this but it confirms everything I've
ever thought which is Black Coffee what
is up coffee doesn't taste that good we
all know this sickening it's sickening
on its own it doesn't taste that good
coffee is just a transportation device
for sugar and milk in my opinion right I
like sweet I like a sweet coffee with
half and half this is hot chocolate
exactly there no yeah what kind of Psych
honestly when I go into Starbucks and I
see someone get a like Frappuccino with
like whipped cream I'm like I trust that
person uhhuh whipped cream oh my God I
want that so bad right 7 a.m. there is a
Starbucks drive-thru I'm not opening my
window in today's world imagine it so
you have have you ever I don't even know
how do you even meet people you would
never go on a dating app you can't go on
a dating app oh God no no no you get set
up no okay I here's the thing uh I will
just float through a doorway and if a
man floats by
me uh we our bubbles pop at this no I'm
actually in a relationship yeah
okay I just don't talk about about
it but I think I'm so grateful to not
have to think about dating let me ask
you do you think
about a wedding like do you think about
the do you have those pressures as
someone that just was engaged got
overwhelmed got freaked out uh realized
I had spent my whole life like
intentionally careening towards W this
goal I was told I needed to achieve in
order to be a a valuable
lovable viable even like sexy woman um
someone had to want me forever someone
had to slap an expensive jewel on your
hand and say like it's like getting
pre-approved for a loan like some
someone has to have said like I would be
with you forever I mean I actually have
this theory that people would rather you
be married and divorced than never have
been married at all if you're like a 45y
old woman 40 45 right like oh at least
someone wanted her someone did want her
right H yeah it's gross I feel like I
when I was younger
yes and
now um not the same way like my goal has
changed to I do want kids okay um my
brother had a little girl recently and
it I I thought for sure I was just a
husk person with no
feelings like I was like I don't know
what this ticking clock means like I
don't know what this means right right
right right I don't I don't have
whatever this is you never had the com
like compulsion you never had and when
you when did it switch when you met your
niece when my niece yeah when this
happened and she and I like baby's faces
Chang like they I don't know maybe it's
know I'm so close with my brother and my
sister-in-law that like the fact that
those two people I love so much made
another person and then I see my brother
she has my brother's eyes she has my
sister-in-law's like lips like she looks
just like both like I felt that like
love and maybe it's because it's these
two people I love but I felt the thing
and now I'm like yeah I think it's also
seeing my brother seeing my brother's
kids May me want kids uh the same thing
and then also seeing him I mean my
brother's like super smart he's the best
but just being like Oh someone in our
family had a kid like we can do like
because I just thought for the longest
time like I can't continue this lineage
like we fuck everything up like we just
should stop this genetic line just the
DNA should stop here and it's a rough
time out there but just seeing how
awesome my brother's kids are going like
you don't they're not going to have my
as long as I know they're not going to
have my
personality well they have a they have a
chance yeah like PE people that are
messes can have kids that are awesome
like and just seeing all of like
certainly a lot of my friends that are
like drunken messes having kids like you
should never have a kid and their kids
are like super cool I mean yeah my my
thing has switched to like I now am sure
that I do want to have kids some point
but that is more exciting to me than
like the idea of a wedding which I don't
care about yeah and like if I ever do
get married it would just be uh
i' quick i' just alope I actually
Googled at one point can you officiate
your own
[Laughter]
wedding hash
co9 and maybe now it's possible I'm just
saying can you what was the answer the
answer was no in
California uh Gavin Nome needs to get on
this now I don't care what else is
happening we can't go to the beach I
there's a lot of things are going to be
on hold just thinking like who the fuck
would I want in this
intimate really like really big moment
other than me and that other person like
who that's so embarrassing like to me
that's so Emar like getting married is
so embarrassed I can't believe you just
said that because that is truly
something that was like like stuck in my
craw that yeah am I I'm sorry to be
Satan about this but like to me wedding
are so embarrassing they're embar but I
think that because we get to perform a
lot we yes you're right we do get to
like dress up a lot because I found
myself being like like what am I going
to go be vulnerable in front of all my
friends that are comedians like I'm just
going to go bomb and and then I realiz
like oh most people's friends aren't
Comedians and performers I'm coming at
this as a jaded person who has to get
dressed up has to put on makeup has to
like be in front of people all the time
time as my job so I would associate it
with being my job it would be like on
your day off do you want to put on
makeup it's like the worst talk show
you've ever had to
do and yeah I just couldn't find an
iteration that I could like wrap my head
around like cuz I think I also as a
performer I was like well this it has to
be hilarious and it has to be and I was
like oh man you know what I mean God
isn't that sick take the mic from the
rabbi you're bombing I got just give it
to me you're bombing like I would be
heckling my fiance's parents being like
you're bombing tighten it up my God now
I need you to have a big giant wedding
just so that let me do a pass on your
speech that like I'll write it I'll
write it that's what I know that I'd
write everyone's speech like punching up
your husband's vow totally just like oh
God like I found myself really like
struggling with a lot of logistics and I
also have like sad like things in my
family and I think it's it was hard to
like plan a wedding thinking like well
would this person come and if I would
have to invite this person and then I
just got very exhausted it's so much
there's so much that has nothing to do
with the actual thing here's my question
I seem very stress are there gonna be
weddings in a
year is anyone ever going to get married
again I think I mean I think if you're
quarantine with your partner and it's
going bad you guys have to break up well
yeah like and if it's going great you
should just stay together forever
because you're never going to be in a
pandemic with another person in your
lifetime again this is a huge thing this
is a giant thing and if it's going well
you're good like I no no no please no I
that that was the first time we had like
a delay where I was
like well another test that I think
about in with people is
like if you got stuck in an
elevator with that
person like how would it Go could you be
stuck in an elevator with your person
for 10 hours you'd have to pee in front
of him oh you you'd have a panic attack
in front of him you'd both have to pee
in the same Corner you'd have to calm
each other down you'd have to wait you
know the fucking Bells going off that's
my the emotional test and I'm you know
the person I'm with I could could be
fucker in an elevator for 10 hours I'm
finding it going both ways I'm finding
it going people that are quarantined
with their person they're like oh this
is like I this only worked because we
both left every day at 8:00 a.m. and
came back at 700 p.m. that's the only
reason this but I'm seeing a lot of
people that's kind of like exciting a
lot of people a lot of guys especially
going I've never been more in love with
my wife number one I had no idea how
much shit she was doing that I didn't
even
know like great I didn't realize she was
like cleaning the bathrooms and doing
the dishes like she was doing all this
stuff that I didn't even know about and
I have a whole new respect and
admiration for
her that's great and what could be
better nothing then I'm seeing a lot of
women that go kind of thought my husband
was a
pussy but he just fucking repaved our
driveway I didn't know he could do that
that oh my God that would be so hot
imagine it you know because it's like
we've never been in this situation
before so all of a sudden you know um a
lot of my girlfriends are like dude like
I had no idea my man could even do this
and like he put a new window Paine in
and like we never would have done this
had we would have called great you
know I fixed I fixed my own my own sink
uh twirly T garbage disposal thank you
fix my own garbage twirly disposal you
mean the violent sharp knives spiral
around yes you touch that thing yeah
that's fix it my s how what was it bro
how was it how well uh the the the the
power strip was
unplugged but before I figured that out
I put my hand in there and I felt around
that is see it's so interesting because
I feel like we both are very brave
people in a lot of ways but very weird
things scare me not the only things that
really scare me
besides pandemics
mhm are
jellyfish oh I'm not scared of be I've
been stung by a jellyfish no yeah where
legs or where in the what body of
[Laughter]
water I mean that too what
a like what body of
water oh my
god um fuck was I in Maryland that
tracks that tracks yeah like like the sh
like um reoboth Beach nocean City Ocean
City wow you've been to Ocean City isn't
Ocean City in New Jersey there I think
is I think there are two but there's one
in
Maryland um I think I was in Maryland
I've been Ocean City New Jersey quite a
bit uh but yeah it was an East Coast
body of water the only thing that scares
me is I I remember one time I was with
Chelsea hendler and we were in a place
called Shelter Island New York I don't
belong in nice places anyway so this is
already a bad idea I was paddle
boarding oh what I I was trying to be
fun so many mistakes I'm
fun I'm fun I'm so fun I'm such a guys
girl I at wings I paddle board like I
was I grew up no water sports I grew up
with I didn't ski I didn't do any of
that shit and then like eight years ago
I started making friends that you know
were and I was like I Chelsea paddle
boards oh she's in fucking incredible at
it incred Chelsea's an incredible skier
she's she's very athletic you have to
have a certain level of confidence that
I think you get at a very young age to
go like I'm going to like skiing to me
is don't get it don't know why it's
legal quite frankly um it's bad you're
just like sliding on knives down 80 M an
hour down like ice like it's a it's just
it's wild to me but so I'm on this
paddle board and it's actually like
there's a second where like this is fun
like I get why people do this I go out I
look down there's truly it's opaque with
jellyfish like it looks like it looks
like a screen saver you would have on
your Mac like just all oh no the giant
purple ones I mean they're beautiful I
got on all fours and just started crying
like sobbing yeah you should and someone
had to come out and get me and like
bring me back in dude they're I mean you
get stung enough you could probably die
jellyfish and putting my hand in a
garbage disposal only two things I'm
scared of well I've done both those
things I me tell the tale so uh you're
like but I'm scared of the drive-thru at
Starbucks I am scared of
flying I think we're all scared of
flying I think there's just we've
normalized it really scared no my body
can't do it can't ignore it and so what
happens do you have to take
something I'm also scared of taking
something you have to pick a fear yeah I
live in fear a lot of the time I'm a
scared of a lot of things that I have to
do um I listen to the podcast and I just
fucking grip it and rip it man that's it
just get there when I get there it's
like I because I have to fly so much
that I feel like oh you have to fly for
your tour when you list your dates it
makes me like feel like I have to throw
up and I just have to like go n because
I'm just like I I I am pretty good at if
I know I have to do something I don't
resist it because I'm like the resisting
is what's going to make this even more
exacerbate this right it's when I hit
turbulence on a plane I do just start
crying and all the fear from all the
flights that I've repressed comes
out I do get hysterical on turbulence
because
when you're flying it's you're so flat
you're kind of like forget you know but
as soon as there's turbulence I'm like I
I'm the person on the plane that just
gets hysterical I can't I uh the last
flight I probably ever took in my life
now that this is happening was I was
coming home right when this like I got
in right as this was happening like as
Lockdown was like from Georgia yeah and
I was the only one on the fucking plane
with gloves I was cleaning everything I
was spring the flight attendant were
like we don't have to clean this plane I
was like ha spray spray pel like I and
no one was like thinking this was a
thing and so I was already coming in
during a pandemic I had gone through
this massive airport I was gonna go home
through LAX I was like oh my God this is
like I'm so scared of all of this and
now I'm also on a
plane and the pilot oh my God no the
pilot said something before we took off
and he goes getting a lot of reports uh
air traffic saying we're going to hit
some pretty bad turbulence you know for
the first hour or so so I need everybody
to just stay in their seats we're not
going to you know I don't want anyone
getting hurt
today I was like oh my sorry oh my God
like I don't want anyone getting hurt
that means we're it's G to be so bad
that shits me flying because that's how
people get hurt during turbulence it's
like not there's nothing you can get
hurt by not having your seat Bel on
because you hit your head or something
but I'm like that that's never really
happened to me but I'm like oh God this
is this is the thing this is that kind
of turbulence that we can't get out of
seed we're goingon to get hurt and he
was really going for it and I was we
hadn't taken off and I was like oh fuck
like should I get off the plane in a
pandemic or should I stay on the plane
and maybe like like I was just was it
gnarly was the turbulence
gnarly
no that's the fucked up part I was in I
was just cold sweat texting everyone I
was like oh my God this is it this is it
I'm not texting my brother was like oh
my God he's like a hold on the baby's
crying like I need do right now like and
we get into the storm because then I I
see what's going on we just go through a
gray blanket yeah I'm like oh God here
we go here we go and I'm like holding on
I'm like I'm like trying to breathe
probably listening to your podcast
trying to breathe this listening and
it's
like you know bumping I'm like oh it's
building it's building it's it's
building it's building God and then
that's that was it for it was an hour
of feeling how fast we were going maybe
but not really not for me not even that
bad no and then I was like are you
fucking shit you could have just not
said said anything said anything I mean
I lost 10 years of my life it's it's so
interesting what like it's like with
this whole this whole pandemic it's been
interesting about this like because this
going to go on for a while and you're
you're but what you just said is making
me think like we don't want the bad news
up front it what that pilot could have
done sort of like if the pilot knew how
like human nature worked he would have
gone like there's probably going to be a
lot of turbulence let's not say
something until we're about to hit the
turbulence well it's been and and again
like Pilots so brave don't know how they
do it yeah so grateful to them yeah
however I've been on both of things I've
been on this which was absolutely not
necessary just put the fast and seat
belt sign
on yeah i' you know yeah and then I've
been on planes with a terrible
turbulence where they didn't say shit
and that wasn't good either so let me
ask you a question so if right now I
think everyone's trying to figure out
when we're going to leave our houses
when we're going to when you're going to
S shoot season two of dollface when
we're going to have function again not
just function again but like like feel
calm feel safe right feel safe right
would you rather and I don't know I
haven't figured out my answer yet would
you rather me say to you you're going to
be in until
December or would you rather me say
you're gonna be in for the next month
I'd rather be in December and then in a
month go it's GNA be another month no
you'd rather just
know uh oh in terms of staying inside I
have a theory that that that they know
they meaning local governments whatever
they absolutely they know we can't not
to I think they know that it's going to
be let's say the Oxford thing or
whatever it is goes great and they get a
vaccine out to Frontline workers in
September right and then the rest of us
get it in October November whatever
that's what's going to happen yeah
that's best case scenario yeah if we're
lucky enough and I think if they were to
say it's till December I think people
would just be like fuck you and they
would just like just Revolt so scary to
it's you know it's like an it's it
sounds insane it's too overwheling yeah
I think it's like it is overwhelmingly
long time I think it's like People for
People Like Us that are isolators and
live to stay home yeah December that's
soon that's
fine um but yeah I do think that they
are doing a it'll be in a month and then
they know it's gonna be longer than a
month but they have to roll it out in
bite-sized pieces so there aren't proba
riots in the streets because it's too
scary for PE I mean like you and I are
fine but people with different
personalities are not fine I know and
it's really like I'm always curious
about managing expectations like what's
too much information what's oversharing
what's going to just make someone more
anxious like that pilot should not have
done that that was a a oh that was a
terrible bedside Manor I knew someone
else on the plane who was military and I
was
like he was even like that was some
bullshit like I yeah it's also like
military he was like that was
unnecessary I'm obsessed with just the
psyche of managing expectations like
like when you're doing takes when you're
shooting a TV show like when someone
goes all right last one all of a sudden
I'm like this the last one which is it's
not I can ask for another but just
psychologically what happens when you
think something's going to happen you
know right it's the anticipation that
really fucks with you really shuts me
down if I mean I've been on a plane and
I was doing all right and then we have
turbulence yeah then I am not all right
for that time but I would rather have
that happen than not be all right for a
very long time for no reason so how is
this a metaphor for relationship so if
you go into a relationship or you're in
your relationship now now and someone
just goes there's going to be turbulence
we're going to fight things are going to
be crazy is that better than the going
in being like this is going to be
perfect and smooth and then the
turbulence hits and you're like this
isn't what I signed up for I expect I
always expect like the worst me too me
too that's why we get along yeah I was
like this is probably gonna like I I I'm
just a not a positive
person in a way it served me kind of
well cuz I'm not
expecting much you good I'm like
wow this is honestly I'd say you're
doing pretty good in terms of your
outlook on life given two girls stabbed
and put blood on a stuffed bunny when
you were a child can you believe that
shit that's so mean right no that is
haunting all right yeah and like I grew
up speak of Haunting I grew up in a
haunted house what does that mean so I
would leave my haunted house to go to my
goddamn home school SCH class where some
girls would stab a bunny rabbit and put
it in my cubby as a
joke like fuck you I'm going home to my
ghosts the ghost in the staircase is
nicer to me than you
guys the Goblins under my bed at least
don't try to kill my bunnies seriously
yeah I know what is that what does
haunted mean to you because I don't know
where I land on ghosts currently um I
mean but it sounds crazy to talk about I
grew up in a house that was built in
1694 wow in Pennsylvania wow it had a
plaque on it once a year the historical
society would do a tour through the
house wow because um it was a famous
house because it was one of the first in
the county where I lived and will um
William Penn stayed there wow so was
called pen Cottage you can look it up
wow it's my old house um and it was uh
the the sight of like a lot of things
like he used it as a it was used as a
courthouse like sometimes there was like
I
mean but shit would just happen in there
like lights going on like the classics
like lights going on enough shit
disappearing from rooms that you know
was
house yes pen Cottage in Windwood yep
that my old house that's wild I know
right isn't that crazy yes so that was
my house I grew up in it's
crazy but like yeah this is kind of if a
you were a
house yes I mean it is the cat dening
it's a great house it's amazing it's
beautiful wow but yeah it was like a
legit haunted house for sure everyone
who lived there my whole family saw shit
we saw stuff we heard stuff things would
like in my I lived in the Attic yeah of
course I have of course shit would FL
shit flew across the room see I have
this all those things theory that
children see ghosts more because we're
not in our sort of like rational brains
as much we in our more creative brains
like I only saw ghosts when I was a kid
I don't believe in anything I just want
to get that off my chest I don't believe
in horoscopes I don't believe in
anything vaccines
science for
vaccines climate change I believe in
science and the fact that my childhood
house was haunted cuz there's just no
other explanation there's no other
explanation but I think when you're a
kid you're more open to it because we're
more creative and our frontal lobe isn't
developed and we're not you know walking
around with all our responsibilities and
the weight of the world on our shoulders
like I remember seeing a ghost very
vividly when I was a kid in West
Virginia and just being like that's just
a ghost like it I wasn't mad about it I
was more like open to it and then but
I've never seen one or felt that as an
adult and I think it's just because I'm
not like open to it and it probably
happens all I've seen some shit as a as
a yeah I saw some shit as a adult really
recently in my 20s my ex had lived in a
haunted building in Hollywood and I saw
shit all over the place there it was so
it was it was teething see I believe not
I believe what you're saying because a
lot of times when you hear you hear
celebrities talk about ghosts seeing
ghosts or having ghost paranormal
activities if it's like a famous
successful because every Super famous
person believes in ghosts and when you
actually hear the story it just becomes
clear that they have help are insane no
they'll be like my purse was like on the
chair and then it was like in my closet
and you're like bitch your assistant
moved
it that was or they're like I hear
footsteps sometimes I'm like that's your
cleaning lady go say hello go introduce
yourself to her you're so you're so
right they like I came home and like all
my dishes were
clean my house is clean no it's like and
then I had this like breeze this like
chill yeah you live in Malibu it's a
breeze no my dad is a scientist and my
dad saw shit that's so cool we all saw
shit that's so fucking cool all right
it's weird and I don't talk about it
much because it makes me seem insane but
it really doesn't because you the reason
you don't sound insane is cuz you're
like yeah I didn't see it then and I did
see it then like you're it's so specific
I'm not seeing shit all the time yeah I
yeah I wish I saw more ghosts actually I
was watching um this thing about haunted
houses and uh I'll send it to you it
might have been in Pennsylvania I feel
like most ghosts probably there's
Pennsylvania's got a lot of old stuff
but and um I did iasa like two
years win it what why are you waiting
till now to tell me this yeah you would
I think hate you'd hate the idea of it I
hate it mostly because you might have to
leave your house I don't take stuff I
told you but this is a I loved it and
here's what I was very resistant for the
longest time like I don't I don't like I
can't believe you I I'm legitimately
wouldn't think that you would want to do
that just as surprised as you are and
had a death in the family I grief makes
people do wild shit that's true I was in
so much pain that I was just like fuck
it I'll do this I'll do this I'll do
this right and uh and I did it and it
was this I didn't have this like
hallucinogenic experience where I like
saw like tiedyed Care Bears and but like
you know I think that it made me stop
hallucinating like it made me realize
that in my everyday life I hallucinate
all the time I oh I don't think this
person likes me I don't think this
person this person like it made me
realize how paranoid I am in real life
wow well the maybe the contrast yes it
was a weird thing like instead instead
of like hallucinating during the iasa I
stopped hallucinating and got really
clear and went oh that's why this person
and I aren't friends anymore oh that's
why this person oh my God that
everything just made so much sense uh in
a way that was really helpful is the
black snakes thing true which is what
aren't you supposed to be like vomit up
black
snakes like that you think you're
vomiting black snakes when you're on
iwasa the things about iwasa is the
people that we've heard talk about it
like anything you're going to hear the
most extreme version of the people that
like want attention do you know what I
mean like the cool normal people that do
I waska aren't talking about it all the
time so I I did puke a couple times just
because I I didn't take it seriously and
I was like I'm not gonna not eat Chinese
food I'm sorry I'm not gonna not yeah it
makes but yeah did you did your was your
puke made of animals it was just puke no
oh okay
okay
I'm just saying what I've heard I'm not
it was just here's the thing I heard so
many people talk about stuff like that
and I did I was like I guess I'm G to
puke up a bunch of snakes and I did it
and I was like I was I also didn't do a
ton I told the guy like let me just like
ease into this I'm a very nor is it okay
is it a powder or like a tea it's a tea
it's a tea that tastes super gross and
it's also you can just do it for like a
couple hours like it's not like I had in
my head that you're just puking and
shitting for like days I think people do
enough to do that for 4 days cuz I've
watched like document I don't remember
what it was but it was like people who
were addicts were like healing with IA
yes which is amazing so like obviously
there's something about it that's
helping people and I think you have to
be emotionally ready for it like you
can't go in being like I don't want to
do this and I like whatever I think
experience you want to get out of it
you're going to get out of it and my
deal was just I want to stop being sad
uh about about this death like I want to
understand death like and like make some
kind of peace with this death I want to
understand what like I made a list of
the things I wanted to get clear on I
was like I want to understand why a
couple people that I have tension with
like why I have tension with them
because this and uh and then I was like
I want to stop uh defining myself
through my productivity right like it
was like a like very specific things and
I want to see myself through other
people's eyes because I assume see me
the same way I see me so and usually
People Like Us way more than we like
ourselves right so I hope so shit but
there's a person in my life who like I
sort of was like in this very
codependent relationship with whether I
would rescue and Loan money and you know
trying to help and kept trying to fix
and kept trying to like and then when I
did the iasco I was like oh my God the
more you try to help someone they just
think you think you're better than them
it's
patronizing ooh you're taking away the
dignity of their experience of course
she's mad at you because she looks at
you and just is reminded of all the
things like it's just like you're not
equals anymore and you and you you got
through all of these
points over within a minute just boom Oh
my God like boom it made so you were
Lucid in knowing what you were trying to
work through while you were doing it I
was taking notes I was my go I broke a
pilot story for this this show that I
was doing I was like oh that's what need
I wrote a show I literally was wrote a
TV show the second night you can't stop
can you but I was like
stop making hits because it just
literally wouldn't like you know what
happened at any given time I feel like I
have lots of different radio stations
going you know like you should be doing
this and you should be doing this and
that wasn't good enough and that was and
you should clean this and now you should
go do this and why'd you do that that
was dumb and you need to more lip gloss
you know there's just so many voices and
when I did it it just took away about
80% of the voices oh my God and then a
lot of the sort of like I was able to
just hear things I didn't normally hear
I was able to I was also just able B to
think about things I hadn't thought
about in a very thoughtful way it wasn't
you know I again I didn't do a ton but I
was like that was incredibly valuable
experience and did and did this last
like did this change you completely
Forever This is the weirdest thing and
you know me I'm as very cynical we're
very similar that way and and I'm very
irly to like you know I've gone on and
on and bloviated about my uh debunking
astrology stuff on here I hate astrology
man it's you Benton said it best Benton
said it best it's a way for girls to
insult each
other without do really doing it you
know well I'm a Gemini and someone told
me at on a set that I had just met that
day she was like what's your sign I was
like oh I'm a Gemini she's like oh
you're blackhearted oh I was like what
honestly bitch just if you don't like me
just say it don't she just met me how
are you what's your like how Hi how are
you what's your sign I'm like Gemini oh
you're same with me black hearted
blackhearted that is such a horrendous
thing to say to I'm sorry and if there
was no such thing as astrology and you
just went up to someone and said that it
would it's an HR violation I mean yeah
I'm sorry I a Tang Noe but because you
said Gemini and and now all of a sudden
you're allowed to just insult me to my
face yeah people like you're a Virgo oh
my God you're like neurotic and
obsessive and like you're such a
perfectionist and you're just like you
could never talk to me like that outside
of this context it's not real astrology
isn't real I'm breaking the story or
you're doing your ASMR asy is
fake and I'm sick of
it and you know what Hollywood's
cancelled so I can say whatever the fuck
want astrology it's the best dude I love
Hollywood being cancelled I literally
was on the podcast the other day and I
was like like hey guess what everyone no
one's been meaner to me in this business
than women
oh you took the mic off the stand you
threw it across the
room got made Benton go by a new one uh
an okay so oh so this was wild so my dad
who had passed like really suddenly a
couple years ago right we talked about
it with girl a little bit and uh happens
to everyone everyone goes through it um
yeah but yeah it's some you don't go
through it
you go through it one time yeah and it's
just a it's a and my dad used to always
say he my dad was very cynical very
misanthropic in a way that I find
Charming I'm sure it Formed me in a lot
of ways uh but he would when he would
like open a bill like he'd be like all
these fucking Liars thieves and worms he
would call he call people worms he'd be
like God that guy's a worm like everyone
was just a Liars thieves and worms and
then if we'd ever be in stuck in traffic
behind some when you go ah fucking
tourists like he would
just everyone sounds great like he's I
mean he was the best he was so funny but
I used to drive me nuts because he would
just like everyone's a liar a thief or a
worm right and sometimes he'd say whores
but I'll try to sort of clean up his
legacy and so it always drove me nuts
right like you're so mean to everyone
it's so negative like when I when he was
alive it was like a big source of
tension right and then um I did the
iwaska thing and I was like I want to
deal with the Greek
that my dad has passed and I just had
this little thing it wasn't a voice it
wasn't a magical anything it was just
like a Insight um where I was like oh he
hasn't passed on like he's all the best
parts of him are you get to carry on
like you get to choose how alive he is
right wow it was just like a little
insight that's so nice like you get to
CH like he's not gone like he's just
everything you do in the way you are is
a result of him so he's very much alive
because whether it's your work ethic
whether it's the way you it like it's
just he's everywhere and that sounds
like I think if I heard that I probably
would be like okay right but I just like
oh yeah that's right he's like
everywhere I look like him I like it's
everything and then like two days later
I was on the phone with I don't know a
work thing and I was like ah those guys
are just liars thieves and
worms I was like it was so weird like I
had never said it before Oh my God it
was just like a little like I like
Channel
him and I just say shit that he says now
all the time and it almost feels like
I'm
possessed I'll be like well you are
possessed by 50% of his genetics
genetics that's true held captive
frankly yeah and I'll be like fucking
tourists like it's just like maybe it
was just like I maybe I just open the
window up to allow what was already
inevitable or maybe that was already
going to happen as you get older or
whatever it doesn't have to that's so
great though it was just like I only got
good things out of it and I'm but I'm
also not the person that's like
everyone's got to do iasa it's like life
changing I'm also not that person I
don't have the per I I don't know the
personality I I know
upfront I took an ambient once oh and um
I stayed awake a little too long no no
no no no no no no and I was like this
isn't good nope no no no no no this
isn't good for me I'm uh one time I
retire from this one time I took uh uh
an ambient in the next morning found out
I had fired my
lawyer oh my God like I started getting
emails like okay just to shore this up
and if you just sign this and I just was
like I can't that is the most wiy thing
to do in a blackout is fire a
rep I can't I hope you have your initial
email I will find it find it and here's
the saddest part is that I actually
really liked him and I I had to just go
through with it cuz I didn't like I
couldn't be like sorry I was you let you
kept it like my
God what was I G to like be like sorry
I'm a fucking junkie oh my God oh my God
that's so incredible like you can't like
you got to commit you got to commit to
the B you saw it through at that point
at you got a new lawyer yes oh my God
yes I
did is that sad that
is dark that's one of the best things
I've ever heard dark times it's dark
times over here yeah every now and then
I just want to like be like sorry like I
he'll figure this out well now he's
gonna know he's a fan of the Pod there's
no way he's not a fan of the Pod you're
not cutting this out yeah no and no and
then look I have these little scribbles
because I met I do have to ask you a lot
of people want to know oh what is the
perfect date for cat Denny oh I hate I
hate that lube up with some purel oh
jump in well I don't like dating or
dates I don't even know what that means
you don't like going out to restaurants
on dates no I hate restaurants I've I
I'm sorry great news for you most of
them are going away okay no no not as
not I don't hate restaurants I hate I
hate okay yeah here's a long answer to a
real innocent question
when I sit down at a in a restaurant
with let's pretend I'm on a date okay
which is not happening um you're
agreeing to sit there for until that
check comes you're that could be that's
like two hours you're being held
prisoner and you can't leave and I have
a thing I have a thing about being being
made to stay somewhere yeah because
socially there's a contract that you
can't just like be like I'm done like
get up and leave during the like during
the Brisa you know what I
mean um so I don't like that uh H I have
a theory that I became a comedian so
that I could leave dinners
[Music]
early I mean I guess fuck I don't like
dates so you don't like going on walks
you don't like going on day trips you
don't you just like someone to come over
hang out watch a movie no get out of my
house no no no I don't let people no no
no I don't let a man into my person
you're
dating I don't know what if he was a
chat bot
like I do okay okay let me be a person H
I love I do like going for a like a walk
okay um going to like a bookstore that'd
be fun oh cute that's cute or Museum I
do love going to museum great adorable
that's nice yeah m
somewhere I can leave from actually one
of my favorite dates ever this is this
is how you know cuz I do think you have
to go out places just because you need
to see how people treat weight staff uh
yes got to see how they interact with
other people that's right the way that
they treat other people that can do
nothing for them and that ostensibly are
beneath the service people you got
that's huge for me made the mistake of
only staying inside with somebody and
going out to a restaurant and being like
Oh my God I'm in love with you but
you're fucking rude to waitresses yeah
that's a big thing and the Tipping thing
also huge huge huge huge and how to make
boring things fun you know like I
remember one of the best dates I ever
went on um was with someone that is
still the greatest relationship um I've
had and we went down to uh the mocha
downtown and we would walk around and we
kept asking the people that work there
how much the paintings
were adorable it was just so dumb and
then they were like no you that's great
like it was just dumb it was like a dumb
bit and we could not stop laughing like
I'm sure we were so obnoxious but like
how much is the it was like a Jackson
Pollock um you know what I mean like
just to be able to be goofy in public is
a good thing to see that's really true
you know it's a good test to see what
kind of person you're dealing with yes
like a museum is someone like hello and
you're like uh or someone who's like Bor
like someone who's like over things like
you have to wait for a table or
something and they're like over it and
you get to see that happen Yu
ew or like when I mean little things
like I always like to like go to like
parks and stuff because when you see
someone see a kid their reaction is good
to like yeah like you're like oh F like
I've definitely done that where I've had
a hidden relationship I have secret
relationships like all the time like
Neil brenon text me the other day he's
like so who are you secretly dating like
you because I'm sketchy I'm sketchy and
I'll have secret relationships and then
I'll bring them out into the world and
I'm just like H you're racist fuck oh
God you're just something where you're
just like I haven't seen you in a
grocery store before and now I just
found out you're a monster God that's a
good test too man should have done this
sooner well now we're all fucked can't
go anywhere I know I can't keep you
forever but I'm going to until you log
out I want you to perfect what's a good
gift to get Cat
Dennings besides a crystal ring oh yeah
um fuck it's a hard
one yeah it's really hard I know what I
would
do I would get you a painting of your
cat
or else I just wouldn't try I wouldn't
try fucking amazing uh I
like I mean I'm so predictable I just I
like books man and I do like diamonds
I'm not gonna lie and say I don't like
what's the best gift you recently got
from like a friend
um I don't oh God uh oh uh well I know
the you just went
somewhere well well for the holidays oh
no my mom my mom is not my mom is
amazing she's not I love the best at
gifts she got me a box of bags of like
paper bags like the kind that are like
wax paper like sandwich bags uhhuh like
Reynolds brand like a box sure and I was
like what and he was like oh when you
the other day when I gave gave
you when I gave you like a garlic clove
in one of these you said you like the
bags so I got you your own
bags thanks like you wrapped
[Laughter]
this a box of bags I know that's my life
um I like a I fuck because for some
people you don't you don't like clothes
like don't get a girl clothes don't do
it just don't don't do it you're going
to get the wrong side it's going to be
insulting don't get me lingerie it's not
going to fit it's going to hurt my
feelings you don't know anything like
I'm I just like always give guys like
little ideas of things to take the
pressure off yeah I don't know something
thoughtful that uh proves that someone
has heard a thing I said one
time you
know no your mom did that didn't go so
well I heard you right yeah so I don't
know I I don't I'm hard I do love mug
loves mugs she loves mugs mommy loves
mugs too we both love
mugs I have vintage horse mugs pretty
much God you have so many mugs at the
same time so many mugs at the
simultaneous mugs I've gotten obsessed
with these like well how many okay I
know first of all is that that's not
that company you sent me that amazing no
but I I want to order some stuff from
there this is I don't know this is just
Etsy I just I go on Etsy at night and
just hoard
mugs same I got I have a stack oh wait
did I move
them in your bedroom my nanny moved my
mugs my best friend from college is
really funny when I first started
becoming financially solvent the first
thing I did was get a cleaning lady not
a therapist not a trainer I was cleaning
lady cuz I was like this is going to be
the I never had this growing up this is
going to be the thing right I'm so sick
of knocking the vacuum on my fucking
Shin like I'm so sick of fucking up my
clothes like and I remember um I had
these like mugs in the thing I remember
my my best friend from college Nicki I I
literally would have like $200 and I'd
spend $1 120 on a cleaning lady I would
be like asking for money she be like
you're asking you're B you need to
borrow money why do you have a cleaning
lady like I could I just I thought if
you had $200 you could spend 180 like
the idea of spending I mean you could
you could but it's like it's not going
to go great long term very dumb
and I remember her just looking at me
going clean your own damn
mugs and we always say that to each
other oh I love I love that I mean
listen I'm not saying no one should have
a cleaning person yeah I'm just saying I
don't I have a uh a cleaning lady that I
love very much she's like family to me
and she's more like a partner she's like
my domestic kind of partner but you guys
are we're together and it's the perfect
relationship uh and she uh I love her so
much because
she nonverbally will judge me in ways
that make me look at myself like she um
like I sleep with a heating pad same
Whitney
whoa what
huh it
tracks makes perfect sense it's cuz
puppy's like a heating pad if they're
orphan and pigs too piglets well here we
are
well it
tracks I also have a heartbeat record
that I listen to I'm just kidding I do I
do white noise well I also do I have to
have a thing around my head I wear and I
also sleep in a full suit um like I
dress like Anie Hall to go to bed like
fully like like a cumber bun like
monocle like I I wear full full
tie I dressed like Lemony Snicket to go
to
bed and uh and so she'll so I have the
heating pad and she'll like put it in a
drawer and then I'll like put it back
out and and it'll be like she'll just
keep moving it like trust me like we're
not leaving this on your bed like this
doesn't need to look like a nursing home
like so she'll move stuff to improve my
choices that's nice which is very is
very sweet like she'll be like no that
said leave my heating pad don't touch my
fucking heating pad ever like but she
will you have multiples because I do
just in case something yeah I have a
plaid one um I have the like this color
one it's this color now like the light
blue see that's a gift a heating pack
that is a fucking great gift great gift
great gift or a weighted blanket great
gift oh God yeah yeah a weighted blanket
I have a weighted blanket but I I'm so
out of
shape that just switching positions for
a week under the weighted blanket made
my muscles
sore this is a true
story picturing you like stuck under
your weighted blanket no just like cuz I
I like move around quite a bit I'm just
like you do have to engage your core in
order to move around I want to do it's
too much it's a lot of work do you sleep
well um no
interesting well it's gotten
I'm very stressed out yeah this is a
intense time I uh I got Millie back I
got my cat back thank God so now I'm
touch and go there for a minute it
really was you were posting photos of
people videos of people cooking I mean
it got dicey wasn't doing good yeah yeah
I have Millie back so now I feel a lot
better I'm sleeping better but but when
I wake up I wake up at like 4 every
morning and then I have
to that was from yesterday that was from
yesterday this is the one from
today oh god oh no was it coffee are you
all
right oh that was a bummer oh I'm so
sorry we're back I'm gonna start putting
those I'm GNA start putting those uh
someone needs to get I need a cleaning
lady what's going on is that coconut
water it's rose water oh God damn it
yeah tree ch go to aroan no someone went
to arowana and they deliver thank God
the one in Calabasas delivers yeah not
going into a grocery store you I'm
saying water um so you wake up what
happens at 4 oh I don't know my body is
just like stressed I mean that is when
we're designed to wake up when the sun
comes up well my brain like it's on up
and then it's on forever and I cannot
like unless I immediately go back to
sleep if I have one thought it's
finished like I can't cuz I do think and
I have pitched this idea before to
Productions no one really was interested
we should be going to bed at 8 and
waking up at 4: like we should shift our
whole I've done that and I did that this
morning last night I fell asleep reading
a
book now you're just bragging I know you
think you're so smart just because you
can
read
no I was reading a book and it's a good
book called in the land of men by
Adrienne Miller I actually it's it's
great it's a it's a
memoir she worked at uh GQ uh in the 90s
and it's her about her relationship with
David Foster walls very good the land of
men is it about she's
Hollywood it's about the magazine World
wow it's really good cool and it it yeah
that's it it did not make me tired or
anything but I mean like it reading a
book a physical book I was just like oh
my God I forgot about
this at like 11: so I didn't get a lot
of sleep but I woke up at 4: it was dark
I was like is my mind on yes it is and
then I just paid up but it's kind of
great there's something good about it I
don't know it was like oh the like New
York Times coid update hasn't even come
in yet this is great that's such a good
way to put it when you wake up early
it's like before you're getting
bombarded by all of the bad news so it's
like this is time this is mine now like
I don't have
to no one can no one's up I love no
one's up it's so simple I mean this is
like I remember when I went um uh to uh
a place in Asia like for vacation like
two years ago as if that's ever going to
be possible again um on a plane 18- hour
flight and I realized I mean the malds
is beautiful but like the thing that was
so relaxing about it is that you were
awake while everyone else was asleep
what was it was obviously stunning but
the best part about it was that I wasn't
getting like Bing Bing Bing like emails
there's something about like when I woke
up at 4 this morning I was like
everything is still fucked up and
horrible
but it's quiet and no one's talking
about it yet there's something
liberating about waking up before you
even get that Pottery Barn email oh fuck
yeah forget
something
no I left it in my cart because I don't
want it
forget
something no bitch that I hate forget
something fuck you
unsubscribe three different ways before
you stop emailing me and then you
unsubscribe and then they send you an
email saying you've successfully
unsubscribed like don't send me an email
or it's like was it something we did
questionnaire oh
God I also resent I know I know you have
more questions and you're being like so
classy but I'm going to make this bad
one more time I resent getting emails
from like expensive sites I bought one
thing from one time being like like
summer Staples nope nope like like a no
this is not the time that was a one
night stand that was that was an
aberration that was not the norm your
expensive shit right now but also I'll I
I'll get it like I know where to
you yeah if we want to spend $9 million
on a fucking mini purse we'll hit you up
you know what it made me realize it's
the same thing with dating in my 20s we
were spam emails to the men we were like
forget something they were like no I
know where to find you oh my God if I
want your business I will reach out to
you and every morning I'm like hey
forget anything oh Whitney like I that's
so true getting spam email made me
realize what men must have felt like
that I dated in my 20s I was the spaming
like forget
something like no no fuck yeah like it's
hurts yeah shameful it's shameful but
it's I do like having those moments
where I am able to really put myself in
someone else's shoes like especially
when it makes me you guys know I love
men and I'm not I'm I'm I make fun of
man I make fun of women too I make fun
of everyone but I was looking at I had a
real bad idea like a month ago two weeks
ago one of the many bad ideas uh I've
had during this shelter in place where I
was like oh my God this is probably
going to go on for like nine
months I should just have a kid now and
knock it out no no no trust me I know I
know it was a wild take I'd had a couple
glasses of red wine I was I was on one
cuz I was like oh this I'll just knock
this out because it's not like it
doesn't seem easy check the box just add
to cart ADD baby to cart and I was like
because like I feel like when we go back
to work it's going to be like we're back
and it'll just be or not it's going to
be really slow and whatever but I kind
of was like okay I'm 37 maybe I should
just have the kid now maybe the universe
is telling me like you have time off
whatever so I sign up for this sperm
donor site just a no I don't I didn't
like I was just looking I was put
dipping my toe in oh God okay and so
just to see what it was like because I
have some friends that have done it and
and so I was looking at it and I turns
out when it comes to sperm I'm such a
shallow asshole I just was like it was
like Harvard educated I was like bitch
let me see that hairline let me see like
oh shit I was like 5'8 no thanks like 63
only like I and I was like oh my God
this is what it's like when a guy is on
a dating app like no there are much
higher Stakes here that's true way
higher Stakes I had this whole new sort
of like compassion of like because I was
it was like mechanical engineer I was
like bitch I don't care what you do like
you know like don't give a shit how tall
are you and I I kind of was like oh my
God like I just turned into a shallow
guy fine you know first of all you're
deciding for another person yes that's
true I just want them to have the best
chances of physical survival
exactly there that's very nice of you I
think I was just like strong immune
system how often do you get sick have
you gotten the flu this
year are you a Gemini what's your blood
type life left Virgo Gemini no thanks a
black heart is a way easier way to go
through life I think yeah I wish wish I
fucking had one I wonder if I'm going to
do this thing we haven't done in a while
and maybe this will be how I finally let
you out of my um web out of my grasp
this is the most fun I've had in years
this is so fun we're going to do part
two everyone's gonna want it oh have you
had any major
injuries oh yeah
what
um okay well maybe not major but I my a
was pretty bad that's right a couple
that's right that's right a couple um I
guess not not knockwood not a major I've
been in a very bad car
accident um as a kid my whole family got
in a fucked up car accident and we all
got hurt is that why you didn't want to
drive later it has something to do with
it yeah we because we lived in rural
Pennsylvania and we would go literally
to a dairy farm to get
milk this is like the olden Charming
yeah I know and um we it was a we were
driving down a dirt road no stop signs
no traffic lights dirt road nothing but
cows and we got T-boned by a drunk
driver oh God out of no I mean like the
odds were insane she T-boned us she hit
me and my mom's side of the
car and uh we were all fucked up my we
all had whiplash we all had injuries but
everyone was all right my mom got glass
in her eye
Jesus bunch of shit happened that's
traumatizing um and I had to wear a neck
brace for so
long I don't oh there's a helicopter
casual helicopter just casual helicopter
just dropping Lysol all over hate it so
much um so just this little cute little
girl with this giant neck brace that I
had to go to the chiropractor and like
get adjusted it was so f fucking awful
but that's bad as I've knocked my teeth
out a few
times yuck nothing too major though yeah
and then a lot of people of course are
going to make me ask you what it was
like cuz your was it your first job was
on sex in the city is that like your
first big job first big yeah my first
big job I had done like commercials yeah
but that was my first big job yeah was
were you intimidated or like that's so
crazy isn't that weird that like Michael
Patrick King was in my first big
audition
and then like worked for very weird very
um I was not intimidated at all in fact
I was kind of an asshole in the
audition because I didn't have we didn't
really watch I wasn't allowed to watch
TV that wasn't like kids shows was it a
phenomenon by the time you had
auditioned yeah ah but we didn't have
cable and I certainly wasn't allowed to
watch sex in the city um but we did not
have cable wow so I left my haunted
house slapped on you know a mesh long
sleeve shirt over a tank put my ghosts
in my purse put like tomag
GOI and I went in there and I had like
the sides and like Michael was in there
and like Darren star was in there oh wow
and um I did it and I had no idea who
they were and I had no idea what the
show was and
um Michael was like I'm pretty sure it
was Michael he was like okay I want you
to come back tomorrow
memorized I was
13 I might have been 12 in the audition
and I and I and I looked at him and I I
swear to you I go I'll have my people
call your
people I left the room I was like fuck
this show and then we were in the cab on
the way back to Penn Station and I look
up and there's just a giant sex and City
billboard on the side of a
building go fuck like a
shit I mean the thing is that when you
audition it's like no one ever gets
anything so what am I going to fucking
memorize all this for not like it's like
I was like I just got this paper bro
like I just got it and so you went back
the next day yeah
memorized and then just fucking mic drop
now a bitch like
bye yeah that's that story that's
intense and then in it's so interesting
because it's like when you first the
idea of you you were like the thing
you're like the thing in Hollywood like
I yeah no I don't think anyone's told
you this thank God I don't think this is
a thing that's true though no I think it
I remember like when I moved to
LA the there was like in comedy there
was like the people to beat right in my
age group right it was like Lizzy
Kaplan there's a girl named ID to field
like if they're auditioning you just
don't go just there's no Point going
they just like don't just stay home and
then you came along and I remember it
was like that was the you would you know
when you just hear about someone you
know yes you did Nick and Norris
Infinite Playlist and that was like yeah
but did you know that was going to be
what it was was it like I just I I don't
really know if that was like a thing or
not no after that you were a movie
star
uh I don't know if has this business so
destroyed your sense of reality that no
you didn't even know that because I
think no I just I think I am being
realistic well because I think what this
is what you're doing what what you're
what is happening right now is so
poignant and profound to me because even
when you are you even you get people
don't understand that even when you are
a movie star TV you get rejected by you
don't get jobs you want but no one knows
that
so right so only you know the jobs you
want you get you get the jobs that you
see people doing and that's not that
many yes but it's it's so weird when
people think you're successful but but
in your own thing you're like no I just
didn't get this job and I didn't get
this job like like Kate Blanchet loses
jobs to Julia Roberts or whatever I'm
making that up but you know what I mean
oh my God I read a really amazing
article Kate Blanchett was interviewed
about this very thing and she was so
self deprecated I was like are you
fucking
serious so it's so interesting but not
that this is not the same thing yes it
kind of is no it's not it's not I'm a an
F minus list actor uh who's been in a
couple of things and that's nice but
whatever I I did Nick nor is really
sweet movie I I can't watch my stuff
I've been in yeah I get that unless it's
been minimum like five years
I can't okay so this brings me to the
question this is not a trick question
okay I'm GNA ask you your favorite
animal we haven't done this in a while
pod listeners and you guys I remember
this from earlier episodes but I it's
been so long that I don't remember they
asked specifically to bring it back for
you okay your favorite animal but not
like your like your cat or not like an
animal you
admire okay very specific answer uh
golden tiger you seen golden Tigers I'm
gonna google it oh God they're so
they're fucking it's it's basically like
you know white tigers and regular tigers
and golden tigers are like the red heads
of tigers oh my God I'm looking
beautiful oh my gosh have you ever seen
a more Beau look how beautiful that
animal is look at those eyes that's also
what your cat looks like just giant I
know that's just a little Milly face all
all animals just I mean that is a giant
melon look at that beautiful
animal stupid nose Okay so give me three
uh ways to describe a golden tiger uh
Stupid nose rare stupid nose say it
again what was the first thing you said
uh rare rare they are very rare like
redhe head of tigers yes rare um oh my
gosh big dumb nose oh my God probably
you don't want that yeah okay um
powerful
okay um
oppressed is that a good
answer
inbr
inbre objectified
Ino trapped trapped abused
exploited there you go oh my God okay
endangered suffering for the benefit of
others oh God oh God I was wondering
when you were going to get hot you're an
a legitimate turtleneck I know and I
turned off the AC for sound reasons look
at you're such a pro okay that's love so
that that is love truly um so now your
favorite article of clothing and it
doesn't it it can be anything from a
ball gown from your favorite Vera Wang
black incredible thing you wore to a
Premiere or it can just be like your I
like my favorite thing to wear or my
favorite like physical clothing item it
can be like I remember when I first did
it I was like oh it has to be like this
incredible thing I and I ended up
picking a hoodie because it it is just
my
favorite because it's I remember it was
because it was just like classic gender
neutral and like cozy or something like
nice you know okay but it can be like a
pair of socks it can be
you know bathing suit like um bathing
suit imagine sorry I couldn't I couldn't
I couldn't even say with a straight face
I like I I I pivoted this
second can you
imagine tube toop oh God your face can
you imagine look no um I have a oh I
have a a sleep shirt that I perfect have
had since I was 15 that I love it has
Andy Haul on so cool okay so it's how
would you describe
it
um
comfortable duh
uh but it is I mean if Andy Warhol is on
it
it's probably
rare or rare no it's well it it was my
brother's favorite brand and I was
trying to like do what he was doing but
I did really love the shirt
I guess
nostalgic because it REM I've had it
since I was 15 so when I wear it it it
has like Soul or something what yeah
yeah it like reminds me of my life I
don't know okay uh that's not an
adjective no comfortable nostalg okay uh
what color like it's black and
white um I know this has something to do
with me so I don't want to say like worn
in so this is how you describe your
vagina fuck a big worn in comfortable
shirt it's all stretched out big baggy
[Laughter]
cozy is this really about my vagina no
no no no oh fuck than nostalgic no this
isn't the pilot of two bro girls okay
yeah thank god um uh
it's a man's shirt so I guess it's all
fuck mascul damn it it's just a goddamn
shirt man soft yes okay
masculine oh for boys oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I mean yeah okay let's
say masculine because it's a man's shirt
and there's a man on it yeah
yes so what did I
say how how old when was Annie Warhol
born
oh God the 50s um okay so Andy Warhol
was born in oh no he's was born in
1928 I'm sorry what he was like big in
the no but no you're right he was like
became a thing in the 50s I thought he
fuck wow I am a dumb idiot no you're not
I I asked I had to Google it what do you
guess where he's
from uh is he from Pennsylvania
Pittsburgh
yes can okay I'm so bad at math it's
ridiculous so what would be Chris can
you help me find out what how old
someone would be now if they were born
in
1928 yeah he minus 202 1928 from 2020 I
know I but that doesn't help me okay
here I'll do it okay great because I
can't either sorry 2020 and how old is
what 19 what 92 he'd be 92 oh okay C he
was yeah he was old in the 50s I think
okay wow I thought he was born in the
50s would have I wouldn't have known
anything trust me I'm okay your favorite
body of
water oh I don't like water at all is
that bad but it can be like a cup of tea
a glass of water a pot a vase with
flowers uh I guess uh uh and you know it
doesn't have to be water are you going I
said a river the New River in West
Virginia just because it's like really
really quiet in some places and really
really rough in other places I like like
Lakes yeah I don't I don't like oceans
or big bodies of water yeah because they
don't care if you die in them yeah no
and they have jellyfish in
them yeah okay I'll say a lake I'll
imagine some kind of Lake a lake because
they I don't see a lot of water
generally you really don't huh plastic
are they I'll think about a pool I'll
think about a nice uh okay po because
they're po pool what guess they uh no no
sharks no uh uh that's safe right I mean
not like like you're in control of the
circumstances clear clean also they're
clean I mean well no it depends what
pool we're talking yeah that's a good
point no no no um safe okay safe um
tranquil okay
um oh
uh
transformative yeah because they are
different depths well no because
sometimes when you get out of water you
feel like reborn
okay right some
people would say that type of thing feel
chilly but yeah I remember a few times I
felt that way uhhuh and pools in what
describe the pool what's the kind of
pool are we round pool are we a square
pool are we a deep pool are we a baby
pool oh God it's just a tiny plastic
pool
um I remembering uh I remembering
specific pool cuz I remember being on
location
somewhere uh I remember being on
location in a hotel somewhere where and
they had a pool there and I
had bought goggles like in the I bought
goggles somewhere and I just sat on the
bottom of that pool wearing
goggles and I felt amazing like it felt
like I was in another world and so I'm
trying to remember that it's like quiet
I mean it's like peaceful and
quiet yeah that's fair I know
otherworldly like if you're underwater
there it's very like otherworldly yeah
that's Perfection okay is this bad not
all it's not at
all this is bad okay no this is very
good you're you have an A so far okay
okay last one oh good good I always fuck
this I always fuck this one up so if
you're in front of your windows and you
open them and like a spring breeze blows
on your face what are the first three
emotions you feel
um hopeful
uhhuh
[Music]
um it's a nice feeling to me I mean like
it's a good feeling yeah to feel that I
I put down for weirdly for me I feel
when it's springtime I feel nostalgic
and nostalgic makes me feel anonia and I
feel like it's going to be over soon if
I enjoy something so for me it gave me
total panic attack the other okay yeah I
like this is such a nice feeling and
it's not going to last forever that's
what nice feelings trigger in but you
can get a bre
breezes are
frequent I'm just saying it you know you
could open a window any goddamn time you
want I you never
know it's a wild time we're in The New
Normal you're right you're right breezes
could be cancelled breezes sometimes
blow up women's skirts and that's okay
okay too might take the breezes out all
right uncertain yeah okay we just
covered that great and uh um connected
yeah that's a good
one and you have hopeful you have
hopeful hopeful you I don't know a
springtime Breeze makes me feel hopeful
because the the trees are exploding yeah
uh allergies out my
I start getting swollen are your
allergies bad by the way they yeah I get
itchy and uh uh my nose gets stopped up
thank God it hasn't been the same
symptoms that are coid because I'd
probably be the person who was at oh the
hospital I don't get cough I just get um
uh nasal I get sinus yeah that's what I
get that's what I get yeah that's the
thing about all this is that half the
people that I know that think they have
Co I'm like you just have allergies take
care just stay home idiot you're not as
special as you
think okay ready
okay your favorite animal yeah yeah this
is again like this is for all you guys
know listening this is a test that Freud
used to give people Freud is
obviously you know knows nothing now
that we look back but it's a funny uh to
me thing that is often pretty on point
it's a way to kind of reveal your
subconscious I tell people that they
should do this on like first dates with
people if you're in quarantine and
you're with your other it's just like
kind of a fun game to play um but it
sort of tells you a little bit about
your psyche without directly asking
someone um about it so your favorite
animal allegedly
supposedly uh reveals how you view
yourself oh shit golden
tiger powerful big dumb stupid nose
that's
true trapped abused
yeah all right trapped in suffering for
the benefit of others
[Laughter]
entertainment it's true I
mean it ain't wrong oh no that's the
problem with it is as soon as I would to
say it's dumb I'm always like yeah
that's tracks it's
tracks and then your favorite article of
clothing uh uh reveals the way other
people view you which is usually
antithetical to the way we view
ourselves so you would be a sleep shirt
comfortable
nostalgic
masculine soft oh for
boys for boys yeah okay oh no and the
reason I was doing this math is like
basically a 92-year-old
man which you kind of true which you
kind of are
it's Whitney I am a 92y old man
everybody knows
it that's how you're viewed so this is
actually very on point all
right and even the black and white kind
of blows my mind that you said that
because Michael and I used to always say
she's from like the black and white
Takis like she's from she's from the 20s
like her face her feet like oh my God
you know you have this like like black
and white movie star Essence to you this
like Soul right that's nice so that
tracks to me um but usually the way you
perceive yourself and the way other
people perceive you are completely
different like mine was a honey badger I
like tough and Scrappy but then the way
I view myself was hoodie like cozy
comfortable warm welcoming like it's
like you know always an interesting to
see how different that is um yeah fuck
favorite body water is how you view sex
ah shit this is the one I couldn't
remember
was I knew one of them was but I
couldn't remember which
one oh what did I say uh can can drown
you uh filled with chemicals
unsanitary full of
germs
disgusting would never do it in public
do it with a shirt on I hate water
that's the first thing I said is I hate
water
you were just
like ew
water fuck oh fuck yeah it uh tranquil
transformative peaceful quiet no
sharks well that's
true I haven't seen a shark in that mode
and
year and then the the opening of the
thing which I always fucking explain
wrong but the opening of the thing is
how you view death ah hopeful e no
that's wrong
connected okay
uncertain well yeah shit hopeful is
wrong I'm not hopeful about dying yeah
but I think it's I think if I get I'm
getting it right it's when you're older
that's how you're going to see it like
you're going to be on your deathbed
hopeful like for the your daughter or
your son like something I don't know
maybe that one always throws me I'm like
how does it no one views death in a
positive way well it's just saying like
a springtime breeze it's such a
positive I I just remember one time uh
when I first did it and someone said uh
that one I said when you open the window
I said
relieved yeah you know
what just the idea it just like made so
much as the idea that someone's like you
have a terminal illness and I'm like oh
thank God God so this is how it happened
yeah oh I'm just so relieved that the
shoe dropped like I've been waiting I'm
just glad it's not a plane watch if I
die in a play in this episode is going
to be so oh I'll go to jail for a murder
I'll be an I'll be an accomplice it'll
be like you knew and you let her get on
a plane you were very are we ever G to
get on planes again not I'm not they've
got they uh I'll send you this article
where they were showing what planes will
look like in the future and it was like
these glass partitions
oh dividing people what n and what about
the air ma'am recycled air it's still
the air yes I'm buy it it's 200 people
in a tu someone needs to make a tube
Elon needs to get on the tube thing it's
just it's that's how it has to happen he
doesn't believe I mean he just tweeted
something pretty wild so I don't know he
tweeted like free America let's all go
back to work oh no bud buddy but buddy
buddy Budd buddy buddy listen my
favorite saying is God rarely gives with
both
hands and I'm an atheist
so I just really like saying that now
you put that puzzle
together that's for you to figure out
figure out you don't get it not my
problem not my problem may God help you
even though I don't believe in God get
it yep I'm listen the diamond that is
catch endings has many facets I'm a
riddle wrapped in a
rhyme and I've been in my house for two
months I've been here for so long but
genuinely this is the most fun I've had
in such a long time to the point where I
have to we I have to stop this is your
computer will just explode I know this
file talking for three hours I know this
file is so big I'm just so happy to see
you I love you let's do this more not
only recording it so that we can burn
more bridges and do more hot
Goss I'm gonna I'm gonna burn more
astrology Bridges oh yeah you'll let me
know tomorrow if you want to cut that
out no I don't want to that I don't want
to cut out is that
wiita spin food my that is my favorite
fucking thing and I put it under my eyes
and I put it well I used to put it on my
face before I got on a
plane m
from the Before Time from the before
times um okay a lot of you guys have
more questions for cat didn't get to all
of them so sorry but I've kept her for a
solid three hours no one has questions
no one has questions for me this is fake
a lot of people had questions for you
I'll send them all to you tough shit get
tough shit if I didn't answer every
question in the world in this three
hours then I then we're out in luck I
was just say I have full on lock jaw
I have what is it called TMJ yeah I full
on TMJ but I love you so much I love you
so much I'm GNA make you do this again
next time we do this I might have your
haircut because uh it's so cute do it
it's so cute and it's really making me
you know what I love about very
90s oh it's so cute Whitney and the side
part is so much better cuz I can't do
the downthe middle part anymore you
looks it's great and by way I don't do
anything to it I don't even blow dry I
don't have to curl it nothing so cute I
I don't have to pull out the curling
iron with all the hair on it uh well
your hair is like fucking majestically
glossy and beautiful what let's try it
let's try it let's try it I'll do it on
the podcast next time I'll just shop my
own hair it what I was thinking about
shaving my
head do okay I'm not going to tell you
what to do pregnant sh my head do a side
do the side be so I think so too just
under maybe just do one side like that'd
be sick you mean like it one side of a
shaved head or like under like this and
then it's shaved just so when you do
your side part that side is shaved yeah
that side shaved then that will look
sick and then if you don't love it you
can just throw it on the other side and
let it grow out a little bit can you ask
your friend Natalie pman how that grow
out process
was probably a year or so cuz then it's
like growing kind of like a weird like
like mullet side mullet and you got to
let it happen you got to let it get it's
a trick it's a tricky one it's a h it's
a hard like hump to together you have
the bone structure for it if you wanted
to do it you could do it now's the time
but you also look really great I don't
want you to do anything you don't want
to do I love you very deeply I love you
deeply I love you deeply there's no way
we're ever going to figure out how to
get this file uploaded no um so this is
just for us this is never coming out
I'll mail it to you there's truly no way
this is going to get on the Internet
it's going to require a GarageBand mpf
that you're going to need a streaming
service Julie have no clue you guys will
see this on Netflix in the fall um I
love you deeply madly and I'm about to
text you a billion things please do and
um uh what if like my oh no it's still
it's still going
what are we rolling I don't even know
are we still rolling yeah it's still
it's still going oh god oh it's going so
fast okay I'm sure it's fine what what
don't delete don't sign out of anything
I'm not I'm not I'm not it's just like
speeding to yeah it's still going holy
shit oh okay what it's fine nothing
everything's good what should he Chris
what should she do should we he just
goes end
it end the show first he goes end the
show first and then we'll
okay I'm gonna press do you want any
closing statement before I press the
stop button so hot um know me too I love
you guys uh anything that you heard on
the show that um you want cat to see
that you have also tag her do you go to
your little tags my tags your little
heart on your Instagram the Heart part
oh um where you can see people that
tagged you right there yes yes yes tag
cat oh that no I don't I can't no I
don't do the heart one I do my I can see
my tagged photos but usually I try not
to look because they're usually like my
face posted on a fake
nude you get those I get a lot of those
and I'm my feelings are always hurt not
by the fact that it was done but by the
body they picked well I'm like you wish
my torso was that long you wish I could
get a weighted blanket off myself
yeah that body would be able to roll
over under weighted blanket if it's
really flattering I'll leave it but
otherwise I usually just report them no
because for I I always have photos
online of me with a phallic object up to
my mouth and people take out this and
put a well I can't wait for you to Poe
the photo of me going like this oh the
number of dicks that are going to be
coming at your face perfect will be you
got nothing else to do but uh yeah you
can watch the tag story so send us tag
us I love you um don't ride elephants as
I always say at the end of every show
and we love you that's how I end the
show most people say subscribe I don't
I'm just don't ride elephants that's all
I ask don't Rite elephants and um don't
keep tigers and Zeus yeah thank you so
much not that much to ask I feel like
we're being
pretty leave them alone just leave it
alone just stay in your lane leave them
alone class it up yeah they're fine
without
you I love you it's cat de I love you
what a treat what a treat for me I
always end these very
awkwardly okay I'm going to press stop
okay
[Music]
by